la séance est ouverte
je souhaite en votre nom à tous
féliciter chaleureusement notre 15
parlementaire et saluer notre capitaine
Pierre Cazeneuve et son président
Jean-François porteario
[Applaudissements]
nos joueurs ont porté haut les couleurs
de nos assemblées lors de cette coupe du
monde de rugby parlementaire en ceux
hissant sur la troisième marche du
podium
[Applaudissements]
ce sont aussi les belles valeurs du
rugby l'esprit d'équipe le sens du
collectif et le respect de l'adversaire
qu'ils ont fait briller autant de
valeurs qui je ne doute pas seront
inspirés chacun en cette nouvelle année
parlementaire
avant de clore cette parenthèse
permettez-moi d'adresser là aussi en
notre nom à tous des vœux de bon
rétablissement au capitaine de notre
équipe de France Antoine Dupont que nous
espérons retrouver très vite sur le
terrain et jusqu'au bout de la
compétition
[Applaudissements]
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement et la première
d'entre elles va être posée par Monsieur
Vincent Decker pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
une fois encore les prix des carburants
flammes à la pompe et mettent à mal le
pouvoir d'achat des Français dans un
contexte d'inflation persistante ils
atteint des niveaux records 2 euros le
litre et jusqu'à 2,10 voir plus dans des
stations de départements ruraux comme le
Cantal dont je suis élu face à cette
nouvelle crise la cacophonie a gagné le
sommet de l'État après avoir dans un
premier temps rejeté toute idée
d'intervention vous avez lancé un appel
désespéré à la générosité des gros
distributeurs une proposition de vente à
perte manifestement improvisée qui s'est
heurtait un refus catégorique un
camouflé qui se double maintenant d'un
désaveu avec la dernière proposition en
date du président de la République le
retour d'un chèque carburant vous
connaissez notre opposition à ce
dispositif source d'inégalités qui au
final n'a concerné qu'un peu plus de 4
millions de foyers ce qui est bien peu
au regard des 40 millions
d'automobilistes
les parents qui conduisent leurs enfants
à l'école les retraités les bénévoles
les artisans les petites entreprises les
professions libérales comme les
infirmières qui seront exclus de ce
dispositif non pas pour autant
l'impression d'effectuer des
déplacements de confort pour reprendre
l'expression du président de la
République madame la Première ministre
notre président de groupe Olivier marlex
vous a demandé d'organiser une
conférence sur les prix de l'énergie
pétrole bien sûr mais aussi gaz
électricité proposition à laquelle vous
sembliez souscrire d'où ma première
question comptez-vous accéder à sa
demande pour répondre à cette crise
d'une ampleur inédite aller voir en
faire revoir la fiscalité sur les
carburants et décider d'une baisse des
taxes qui représentent plus de la moitié
du prix à la pompe des taxes que votre
prédécesseur Édouard Philippe s'était
empressé d'augmenter en son temps avec
les avec les conséquences sociales qu'on
a tous à l'esprit
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
oui madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Vincent des cœurs
nous connaissons la position de votre
groupe sur les carburants
c'est soit de baisser la TVA sur les
carburants coût 10 milliards d'euros
soit la proposition de XV Bertrand une
remise à la pompe coût 12 milliards
d'euros par an vous ne pouvez pas nous
réclamer de rétablir les finances
publiques de baisser la dette de la
France et d'engager 10 milliards d'euros
de dépenses supplémentaires sur
l'énergie que nous ne produisons pas
pourquoi les taxes sont élevées parce
que la politique était menée en France
depuis le début ces deux taxer
lourdement une énergie que nous ne
produisons pas pour financer une énergie
que nous produisons qui est l'énergie
nucléaire et nous garderons cette
politique baisser les taxes sur les
carburants monsieur desker c'est une
triple aberration c'est une aberration
écologique car c'est financé le fossile
c'est une aberration budgétaire parce
que ça creuse je trouve de la dette de
l'État et tu délaboration géopolitique
parce que l'argent va tout droit dans la
poche de Monsieur Poutine nous nous
avons d'autres propositions s'il vous
plaît nous avons d'autres propositions
que nous mettons en œuvre nous avons
obtenu de Total qu'il plafonne le prix
des carburants à 1,99 €. nous
obtiendrons des distributeurs qu'ils
mettent en place des prix coûtant à la
pompe dans chacune dans chacun des
magasins de la distribution et nous
mettrons en place une indemnité
carburant transport sur laquelle
monsieur Decker vous devriez nous
rejoindre vous voulez aider ceux qui
travaillent et bien nous nous apportons
une aide à ceux qui travaillent et pas
ceux qui prennent leur 4x4 pour se
rendre en vacances
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Decker
monsieur le ministre les Français
attendent une réponse une réponse
immédiate et à l'horizon de 2024 une
réponse pour tous ceux qui travaillent
et tous ceux qui ne peuvent pas se
passer de leur véhicule merci
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Maya pour le groupe Renaissance
merci
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre le réchauffement
climatique appelle la mobilisation de
toutes et tous dans son commun dans ce
combat commun la France doit être à
l'avant-garde depuis 2017 beaucoup a été
fait rien que cette année notre majorité
a voté pour relancer la filière
nucléaire accélérer le développement des
énergies renouvelables et
réindustrialiser la France en misant sur
les technologies de demain disons-le
aucune majorité n'a fait autant pour
l'écologie que celle qui s'y habitue
depuis 6 ans sur ses bancs
mais il faut que nous accélérions car le
défi est immense latin de la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050 et rien qu'en 2030
c'est 55% de nos émissions de CO2 en
moins madame la Première ministre à
travers la planification écologique dont
vous avez la charge notre groupe attend
des actes forts elle doit être
irréversible et met à contribution
l'ensemble des secteurs car la clé de
notre réussite collective c'est la
production massive d'énergie des
carbonées c'est l'accélération de la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
c'est la construction de nouvelles
infrastructures de transport c'est enfin
la reconquête de notre souveraineté
alimentaire
le projet de loi des finances qui sera
examinée par l'Assemblée cet automne
doit aussi servir cette ambition
écologique ayons comme impératif de
mettre en oeuvre une écologie de progrès
de solutions basées sur l'innovation et
les incitations non une écologie
punitive basée sur la décroissance
la loi de production d'énergie annoncée
par le président de la République
s'inscrit dans cette perspective tout
comme la programmation pluriannuelle des
financements de la transition écologique
proposée par mon groupe madame la
Première ministre quels seront les
prochains jalons pour que votre
gouvernement mette en temps mettre en
oeuvre pour faire de la France la nation
ouverte je vous remercie merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Sylvain Maillard
vous l'avez dit l'urgence est là elle
est incontestable et c'est pourquoi le
président de la République a décidé
d'agir avec force depuis six ans et
depuis 2019 chaque année nous faisons
mieux que nous objectives en termes de
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé
notre engagement est connu nous devons
réduire nos émissions de 55% d'ici 2030
pour cela il faut accélérer car nous
devons faire autant en 7 ans que ce que
nous avons fait en 33 ans pour y
parvenir dès l'accompagner électorale le
président de la République a porté une
idée inédite la planification écologique
dont il m'a personnellement confié la
charge
aujourd'hui après plus d'un an de
travail notamment avec les ministres
Christophe Béchu Agnès panière une
hachée Marc féno et Roland Lescure nous
avons désormais un plan secteur par
secteur dont le président de la
République a présenté hier les grands
enjeux et les prochains jalons comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le souligner auprès des
chefs de parties et des membres du CNR
c'est d'abord un plan de souveraineté il
va nous permettre de sortir de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles
notamment du charbon d'ici 2027 et de
continuer la réindustrialisation verte
de la France c'est un plan de croissance
vertueuse alors que la décroissance nous
priverait des ressources pour financer
notre modèle social notre plan nous
donne les moyens d'investir et d'innover
c'est un plan qui ne laisse personne
dans l'impasse nous allons accompagner
tous les Français offrir des solutions
alternatives décarbonées accessible à
tous je pense notamment à l'offre de
leasing à 100 euros par mois pour
accéder à un véhicule propre fabriqué en
Europe la planification écologique c'est
la radicalité des résultats sans la
brutalité des mesures c'est une
répartition efficace et équitable de
l'effort et puis ce plan c'est d'abord
un plan pour les territoires et dans les
prochains jours les ministres iront à la
rencontre des élus région par région
pour adapter notre planification
écologique à la réalité des territoires
ce plan c'est du concret c'est une
accélération de la rénovation des
logements et des bâtiments publics c'est
un million de pompes à chaleur fabriqués
en France d'ici 2027 c'est la
décarbonation des 56 industriels les
plus émetteurs enfin c'est un plan
financé et dès l'année prochaine nous
investirons 7 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour la transition
écologique monsieur le Président
Maillard je connais votre investissement
celui de votre groupe
ainsi que de toute la majorité en faveur
de la transition écologique aujourd'hui
notre plan nous avons un plan ambitieux
et crédible et avec vous avec tous les
territoires avec toutes celles et ceux
qui veulent agir pour le climat et pour
la biodiversité nous sommes prêts à le
mettre en œuvre je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Madame Aurélie trouver
pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la Présidente chers collègues
monsieur le ministre Bruno Le Maire vous
avez affirmé qu'il n'y a pas je cite
d'appovrement de la société française et
ça dire que les centaines de milliers de
personnes qui désormais doivent sauter
des repas n'existe pas pour vous car
c'est maintenant le cas d'une personne
sur trois dans ce pays et ça dire que
toutes celles qui allongent les fils de
l'aide alimentaire n'existent pas pour
vous nos concitoyens ont faim et dans
quelques semaines ils auront froid faute
de pouvoir payer le chauffage
face à la flambée des prix vous êtes
enfermés dans votre extrême libéralisme
mais vous voulez au fond rien faire mais
comme il faut tout de même occuper
l'espace et bien vous faites n'importe
quoi vous sortez donc CESU la revente à
perdre une ineptie totale qui a coalisé
tous les acteurs économiques contre vous
un chapeau
depuis le président a reculé et annoncé
d'autres gadgets tout à fait
inutiles le chèque carburant la vente a
pris coûtant qui au mieux feront gagner
quelques euros par mois aux Français et
encore à une partie seulement vous
faites n'importe quoi parce qu'au fond
vous refusez de vous en prendre aux
riches aux multinationales que vous
servez depuis le début grâce à vous les
marges des grands pétroliers des
multinationales de l'agroalimentaire
n'ont jamais été aussi élevées dans
l'histoire des statistiques et ce sont
bien ces marges qu'il faut monter les
profits des actionnaires mais aussi les
prix de l'essence et de l'alimentation
le président Macron nous annonce
maintenant un accord de modération des
marges mais un accord avec qui ça fait
des mois que vous suppliez que vous
quémandez auprès des multinationales
sachant très bien qu'elle ne
ranhosseront jamais d'elle-même à leur
raison d'agir nourrir les dividendes
quelle comédie ce serait drôle si ça
n'était pas dramatique pour nos
concitoyens monsieur le ministre quel
nouveau drame pour que vous agissiez
allez vous bloquer le prix des
carburants en sortie de raffinerie
refuser le code du commerce pour
encadrer les marges tout cela est
parfaitement possible et vous le savez à
moins que vous ne vouliez rester dans
l'histoire comme le gouvernement qui a
ramené la France à l'état d'un pays qui
a faim je vous remercie ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique
[Applaudissements]
députés madame la députée Aurélie
trouvée je ne sais pas si nous nous
faisons n'importe quoi mais vous vous ne
faites rien si vous aviez tant
d'attachement au pouvoir d'achat des
ménages pourquoi est-ce que vous n'avez
pas voté le bouclier tarifaire sur le
prix du gaz pourquoi est-ce que vous
n'avez pas voté le bouquet tarifaire
c'est le prix de l'électricité pourquoi
vous n'avez pas voté la revalorisation
des retraites pourquoi vous n'avez pas
voté la revalorisation du RSA pourquoi
vous n'avez pas voté l'indemnité
carburant transport vous refusez tout ce
qui peut aider le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages en France par opposition
idéologique à cette majorité et par
indifférence total aux souffrances et
aux malheurs de nos compatriotes voilà
la réalité politique madame la députée
alors il est toujours temps il est
toujours temps pour vous convertir dans
quelques semaines et dans quelques jours
va être examiné au Parlement le projet
de loi de finance pour 2024 il comporte
une revalorisation de tous les minima
sociaux la voie très vous oui ou non il
comporte une revalorisation des
retraites de 5,2%. le vote et vous oui
ou non il comporte 10 milliards d'euros
d'aide pour payer la facture
d'électricité des ménages français la
voie oui ou non il comportera une
indemnité carburant transport qui permet
de réduire de 20 centimes d'euro par
litre le coût du carburant pour ceux qui
travaillent la voie très vous oui ou non
madame la députée un peu de cohérence
votre attachement au pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et de pure façades la réalité
c'est que par purée de logis vous
refusez de voter nos mesures et des les
Français soutenez nos mesures
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur le Président
Chassaigne pour le groupe GDR
madame la Présidente de madame la
Première ministre la situation sociale
de notre pays a atteint un seuil
d'alerte sans pareil elle est explosive
malgré cela le président de la
République a une nouvelle fois versée
dans l'auto-satisfaite nous expliquant
que ça pourrait être pire dans le même
temps Bruno Le Maire en est encore à
quémandé quelques efforts aux uns et aux
autres sans rien obtenir et pour cause
vous tremblez à l'idée de contraindre
l'urgence est pourtant sous vos yeux 40%
des étudiants déclarent renoncés à des
soins 42% des Français au SMIC se prive
d'un repas par jour près d'un enfant sur
cinq et touché par la pauvreté plus
violent encore et la situation subit par
les habitants habitants des territoires
dix outre-mer allant pour certains
jusqu'à être privé du droit fondamental
à l'eau potable à un préparation
demi-mesure voilà vos seules dans sa
l'inflation galopante et la stagnation
des revenus à méprisant le Parlement en
maltraitant notre démocratie un matin la
colère plutôt que de l'entendre vous
êtes coupé du peuple et de ses réalités
nos propositions sont sur la table
largement soutenu dans tout le pays
indexation des salaires sur l'inflation
augmentation des pensions
blocages des prix des biens et de
première nécessité sortie du marché
européen de l'énergie taxation des super
profits nous les porterons aux côtés de
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
le 13 octobre prochain comme la rappeler
mon collègue Fabien Roussel la question
sociale celle de la vie chère et la
question de la rentrée la question
centrale madame la Première ministre
n'ajoutez pas de la colère ou désespoir
agissez avant une nouvelle explosion
sociale
entendez-vous enfin nos propositions
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Première ministre
si madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président André Chassaigne
je suis bien conscient de monsieur le
Président des difficultés que rencontre
certains de nos concitoyens dans
l'Hexagone comme dans les outre-mer face
à l'inflation qui dure depuis plusieurs
mois j'ai une conviction la solution
durable pour le pouvoir d'achat c'est
l'emploi cette conviction c'est celle de
mon gouvernement et je sais qu'elle est
largement partagée sur sur les bancs de
cette émission y compris dans votre
groupe alors depuis six ans nous menons
des réformes courageuses qui donnent des
résultats de millions d'emplois ont été
créés des usines ouvre à nouveau et le
taux de chômage est au plus bas depuis
40 ans
alors aujourd'hui nous gardons le cap
car cette politique économique produit
des résultats mais je suis d'accord avec
vous monsieur le Président Chassaigne
certaines situations restent choquantes
et il faut que le travail paye mieux je
pense notamment au temps partiel subit
je pense à certains métiers essentiels
encore sous-payés les caissières les
agents d'entretien et puis il est
intolérable que certains soient
condamnés à passer l'ensemble de leur
vie professionnelle au SMIC sans aucune
perspective de carrière ces questions
elles seront au cœur de la conférence
sociale que je réinirais avec le
ministre du Travail Olivier du soft le
16 octobre avec l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales et patronales
et puis j'ajoute que nous agissons pour
le pouvoir d'achat de tous depuis ce le
début de cette période d'inflation avec
les boucliers tarifaires les remises
carburants avec la revalorisation des
petites retraites avec la
déconjugalisation de l'âge à partir du
1er octobre je note qu'aucune de ces
mesures n'a été votée par votre groupe
et cet financier exceptionnel nous
l'avons porté en responsabilité mais en
demandant à tous les acteurs de prendre
leur part c'est notamment le sens cette
année de la taxation des rentes des
énergéticiens et Monsieur président
Chassaigne vous m'interrogez en
particulier sur la situation de nos
concitoyens des Outre-mer c'est le cœur
des mesures structurelles que j'ai
annoncé le 18 juillet dernier à l'issue
du comité interministériel des Outre-mer
avec la réforme de l'octroi de mer des
mesures pour le prix des carburants de
meilleure liaisons attériles dans les
Caraïbes nous agissons concrètement pour
nos compatriotes ultramarins face à la
vie chère je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à monsieur le Président
pencher pour le groupe Liot madame la
Première ministre beaucoup de nos
patriotes souffrent inflation
alimentaire coût de la rentrée
ose des carburants selon une récente
étude de l'INSEE 9 millions de Français
sont en situation de privation
matérielle 42% des plus précaires aurait
supprimé un repas il est urgent d'agir
pour les aider chaque jour dans nos
permanences nous entendons des
situations de détresse des difficultés à
boucler les fins de mois et les
associations d'aide alimentaire nous
alertent elles sont débordées
la semaine dernière nous vous avons fait
plusieurs propositions dont un chèque
carburant immédiat pour les ménages
modestes et les classes moyennes
contraints d'utiliser leur voiture le
président vient de reprendre notre idée
c'est bien mais le compte n'y est pas il
y a trop d'oublier moins de 5 millions
de personnes sont concernées et le
montant
trop modeste 100 euros il faut davantage
et c'est à plutôt à 10 millions de
Français qu'il faudrait l'envoyer de
plus les normes inflation de produits
alimentaires augmentent la pauvreté une
aide ciblée fut promise par le président
puis enterré à plusieurs reprises le
chèque alimentaire nous demandons sa
mise en place immédiate pour les ménages
les plus modestes les travailleurs et
les petites retraites quant allez-vous
le mettre en place il faut aussi penser
à notre jeunesse remettre le repas 1
euro pour les cantines pour les
étudiants et augmenter les bourses pour
financer ces mesures le groupe iode a
proposé des économies comme la baisse
des dépenses pour les cabinets de
conseils
par exemple ou autre l'augmentation des
taxes sur les mégas profits et une
mission flash sur les 180 milliards
d'aide annuels aux entreprises madame le
Premier ministre quelle nouvelle mesure
allez vous prendre en urgence maintenant
pour aider nos concitoyens qui souffrent
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs le député monsieur le
président Bertrand pencher alors je le
redis monsieur le Président pencheur je
mesure pleinement les difficultés de
certains de nos concitoyens face à une
inflation forte depuis plusieurs mois
notamment sur les prix alimentaires et
alors que les prix des carburants ont
fortement augmenté ces dernières
semaines des difficultés dans l'Hexagone
comme dans les outre-mer ou les Français
sont confrontés à la vie chère dans ce
contexte monsieur le Président il faut
le dire mon gouvernement a protégé plus
qu'aucun autre gouvernement en Europe je
pense au bouclier tarifaire qui a limité
la hausse des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité je pense à la remise
carburant puis à l'indemnité carburant
travailleur je pense aussi à la
revalorisation des petites retraites qui
entrent en vigueur à partir de ce
mois-ci et qui permettra à 1,7 millions
de nos concitoyens de toucher en moyenne
600 euros supplémentaires par an je
pense enfin à l'indexation sur de toutes
les prestations sociales et des
retraites qui sera reconduites en 2024
cela représente un effort de 20
milliards d'euros l'année prochaine
monsieur le Président pencheur face aux
difficultés des Français nous allons
continuer à agir comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République nous allons
reconduire l'indemnité carburant pour
les Français qui travaillent et qui ont
besoin de leur voiture c'est une aide de
100 euros qui accompagnera les plus
modestes et les classes moyennes c'est
l'équivalent d'une remise de 20 centimes
d'euro par litre vous m'interrogez sur
les étudiants je rappelle que nous
prolongeons les repas à 1 euro pour les
étudiants boursiers tous les étudiants
en difficulté que nous augmentons nous
aurons doublé le montant des aides aux
banques alimentaires en 2023 par rapport
à 2021 et nous allons augmenter le fond
alimentation durable pour permettre à
chacun d'accéder à une alimentation de
qualité mais dans ce contexte monsieur
le Président pencher chacun doit prendre
sa part et nous devons utiliser tous les
leviers à notre disposition c'est
pourquoi je réunirai tout à l'heure les
retraits tous les acteurs de la filière
des carburants ils savent que nous
attendons de leur part une mobilisation
exceptionnelle à la hauteur de l'enjeu
je leur passerai des messages simples
baisser les prix faire plus de
transparence sur les marges et aider les
Français à trouver les meilleurs prix
près de chez eux vous le voyez monsieur
le Président pencheur face à l'inflation
mon gouvernement agit chacun doit
prendre sa part et je sais pouvoir
compter sur votre soutien pour le
pouvoir d'achat des Français je vous
remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Cyril
Isaac Sibille pour le groupe démocrate
merci Madame présidente ma question
s'adresse à Aurélien Rousseau ministre
de la prévention et de la santé monsieur
le ministre toutes les politiques
publiques partagent la vision de leur
action au moyen de débats autour de leur
stratégie ou de loi d'orientation pour
la santé lors de la dernière législature
nous avions un cap ma santé 2022
aujourd'hui avant d'examiner le PLFSS
qui n'est que la traduction budgétaire
annuelle d'une politique les
parlementaires ont besoin de connaître
votre vision vos services travaillent
actuellement depuis plusieurs mois sur
un document qui définit la trajectoire
pure annuelle de la politique de santé
ce document s'appelle la stratégie
nationale de santé dans ce document une
place importante est faite à la
prévention c'est pourquoi nous saluons
l'annonce de deux mesures phares du
prochain plffs la vaccination
généralisée contre le papillomavirus et
le traitement préventif contre la
bronchiolite
pour qu'une politique de prévention soit
efficace nous devons concentrer nos
efforts sur quelques priorités je vous
en proposerai deux le surpoids et la
santé mentale à noter que beaucoup de
propositions intéressantes figurent dans
cette stratégie nationale de santé je
conseille à tous mes collègues d'en
prendre connaissance
dont une proposition que j'ai défendue
la création d'un brevet de santé
publique et de formation de 300 000
secouristes en santé mentale monsieur le
ministre ma question est la suivante
pouvez-vous nous proposer au titre de
l'article 50-1 de la Constitution un
débat devant le Parlement et donc devant
la nation exposant la stratégie
nationale de santé votre stratégie un
débat essentiel pour tous les acteurs de
la santé un débat en amont du pffss nous
permettant de connaître votre vision vos
objectifs vos priorités afin d'éclairer
le débat budgétaire que nous allons
bientôt avoir bientôt avoir je vous
remercie
et de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
vous avez raison nous avons besoin d'une
stratégie de santé pluriannuelle évalué
une stratégie de santé qui soit aussi
débattue régulièrement devant le
Parlement mais nous avons besoin de la
replacer dans un cadre politique que ce
ne soit pas simplement des indicateurs
et des chiffres et ce cadre politique il
est d'autant plus important que nous
avons aujourd'hui trois grands
changements et depuis vous l'avez cité
ma santé 2022 et depuis de très
nombreuses initiatives ont été prises le
Ségur de la santé pour améliorer le le
rémunération des soignants nous avons
aussi des lois qui ont été initiées par
le mal par le Parlement je pense à la
PPL le risque mais nous avons aussi la
crise du covid qui nous a fait
progresser sur de très nombreux
chantiers la deuxième raison pour
laquelle je pense que nous devons avoir
ce débat c'est que vous l'avez dit le
député le virage préventif il est en
cours il est pris vous avez cité en
particulier la campagne de
d'immunisation contre la bronchiolite je
suis très heureux de vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui cette campagne elle est
une réussite exceptionnelle puisqu'on
est à 60 à 80 % de taux d'adhésion dans
les maternités le vaccin contre le
papillomavirus vous avez cité et vous
avez raison de d'y revenir le sujet de
la santé mentale qui est majeur le sud
du sport santé qui est majeur sur la
santé mentale nous sommes déjà à 68000
secouristes de santé mentale sujet que
vous avez porté donc oui nous devons
avancer sur ce débat politique et nous
le devons d'autant plus que les
soignants ils ont besoin de savoir
quelle est notre plan où on va les
années qui sont devant nous vont encore
être difficiles mais nous avons les
ressources pour y répondre et nous
devons se débat et cette clarté à la
fois aux soignants et aux Français merci
merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur Alexandre
Loubet pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
Elisabeth borne madame la Première
ministre des dizaines de milliers de
clandestins débarquent sur les côtes
européennes comme à lampe p12a cette
immigration massive coûte des milliards
d'euros pour le contribuable elle a
grave notre insécurité et elle menace
notre identité alors que les Français
attendent de la fermeté contre
l'immigration clandestine vous vous
préférez l'encourager vous préférez
l'encourager en refusant d'examiner les
demandes d'asile dans les pays d'origine
en refusant de supprimer le droit du sol
et l'aide médicale d'État ou encore en
refusant de contrôler nos frontières
européennes et nationales pire vous
n'exécutez que 7% des expulsions vous
allez régulariser les clandestins dans
les métiers en tension et vous soutenez
le PACT européen des migrations pacte
qui permettra à la Commission européenne
d'imposer des migrants à en France sous
peine d'amande madame la Première
ministre d'ici 2050 la population
africaine va doubler elle atteindra 2,5
milliards de personnes face à cette
bombe démographique si nous ne voulons
pas que la France et l'Europe
disparaisse nous devons mettre un terme
au laxisme migratoire pour défendre nos
frontières secourir et reconduire les
bateaux de migrants qu'attendez-vous
madame la Première ministre pour
soutenir le blocus maritime demandée par
l'Italie pour stopper cette submersion
et dissuader l'arrivée de migrants en
France qu'attendez-vous pour agir
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci merci madame la Présidente et
Messieurs débutez monsieur député c'est
bien quelque chose que nous avons appris
depuis plusieurs mois c'est que les
campagnes électorales démagogiques pour
ceux qui voulaient le brexit ou pour
ceux qui promettaient la non migration
en Italie de vos amis sont des campagnes
qui montent aux Européens et vous auriez
pu profiter d'autres questions pour vous
excuser pas simplement des chiffres faut
que vous avez évoqué pas simplement des
contre-vérités que vous avez signifié
mais pourquoi mais pourquoi Monsieur le
Député alors si le pacte migratoire
était si mauvais monsieur Selvini et
Madame Meloni l'ont-ils soutenu son
proposition française voilà quelques
mois vous êtes totalement
schizophrénique vous refusez que nous
réglions les problèmes même quand vos
amis soutiennent la proposition du
Président de la République les contrôles
aux frontières européennes c'est une
proposition du Président de la
République que vos députés au Parlement
européen ont refusé l'enregistrement des
étrangers
aux frontières de l'Europe c'est une
proposition que on vous refusez au
Parlement européen et si nous protégeons
pas nos frontières aujourd'hui au
Parlement européen c'est à cause des
députés du rassemblement national un
séjour Chris
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Loubet
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
quand on veut on peut et justement notre
allié Matéo Salvini lorsqu'il est
terminé de l'Intérieur a réussi à
baisser de près de 80% l'arrivée des
migrants sur le solitaire et si vous
êtes si fier de votre bilan pourquoi
vous ne voulez pas consulter les
Français par référendum la réalité c'est
que les Français des approuvent votre
politique il vous sentiront aux
élections européennes du 9 juin
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur député vous pouvez courir après
la démagogie de Mario Maréchal-Le Pen
mais ne faites pas la campagne des
européennes de l'extrême droite sur le
dos des Français la vérité monsieur le
député c'est que vous ne savez pas quoi
dire devant la défaite l'idéologie de ce
qui monte au peuple quand il se présente
aux élections la vérité comme l'a dit
Madame mélodie c'est quelle solution
elle est européenne la vérité c'est que
vous appelez la Commission européenne
quand il y a des problèmes la vérité
c'est que vous couvrez après la
démagogie et vous espérez que le bon
temps joue pour vous grâce aux policiers
grâce aux gendarmes français grâce à ce
que va faire l'Europe nous vous faisons
mentir il y a 225 000 demandes d'asile
en Allemagne il y en a qui sont mis en
France c'est la réussite de la majorité
pas la vôtre
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Brun
pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse madame la Première ministre et
j'y associe mon collègue Sébastien de
l'augu madame la Première ministre nos
artisans boulangers sont en deuil alors
qu'ils viennent de perdre durant les
derniers jours l'un des leurs à
Marseille en boulanger a effectivement
mis fin à ses jours comme tant d'autres
avant lui comme 25% de nos artisans qui
déclarent aujourd'hui réfléchir et
penser au suicide qu'en 40% d'entre eux
avouent avoir déjà pensé passer à l'acte
la situation aujourd'hui de nos
boulangers de nos artisans est
absolument catastrophique ils sont pris
à la gorge par l'explosion des prix de
l'énergie et en particulier de
l'explosion des prix de l'électricité
que vous n'arrivez pas à juguler comment
en effet justifier qu'aujourd'hui notre
pays avec EDF produit électricité à 60
euros du mégawattheure EDF l'avant à 42
euros du mégawatt assez concurrent et
nos boulangers en moyenne dans les
offres de contrats la paie à 700 euros
du mégawatt
c'est un pillage organisé madame la
Première ministre et nous ont nous avons
voté ici souverainement à l'Assemblée
nationale une proposition de loi pour
mettre fin à ce chaos énergétique elle a
été adoptée deux fois par l'Assemblée
nationale une fois par le Sénat et elle
sera bientôt examinée cet automne madame
la Premier ministre alors que le
Président de la République à hier
annoncé au Conseil national de la
refondation vouloir rétablir un prix
d'électricité conforme à 60 euros du
mégawattheure est-ce que cette fois-ci
enfin le Gouvernement soutiendra notre
proposition de loi
merci
la parole est à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre des petits
témoignages entreprises du tourisme
et de l'Artisanat du commerce dans le
désordre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député brun
je souhaiterais d'abord peut-être au nom
du gouvernement mais j'en doute pas au
nom de la représentation nationale
avoir un mot de soutien à l'endroit de
la compagne de Monsieur au Texier qui
camifa un séjour hier mais aussi assez
très proche à son meilleur ami
et à tous en entourage je vous réponds
avec sincérité j'ai appelé le préfet ce
matin les services de la Direction
générale des finances publiques aussi et
je connais l'honneur du Parti socialiste
et de ses membres et des politiques en
général et je sais
qu'on ne mélangera pas tout et je sais
que vous ne ferez pas de récupération
politique là-dessus
le commerce de Monsieur au Texier
n'avait pas de difficultés en matière
d'énergie j'ai vérifié l'intégralité des
dettes fiscales des dettes sociales mais
aussi sa situation auprès des
fournisseurs
et je sais qu'on peut compter sur le
soutien entier de la représentation
nationale à l'endroit de cet homme qui
s'est donné la mort hier
ce qui est indécence et la récupération
politique
ce qui est indécent c'est de tout
mélanger et ce qui est indécent c'est de
lier des choses qui n'ont pas à être
liées
je vous le redis certains députés de
votre groupe madame panot ont d'ailleurs
puisque ça s'est passé dans leur
circonscriptions pris à tâches du préfet
Étienne les informations à votre
disposition si l'origine de ce drame un
quart de seconde vous intéresse pour ce
qui est du prix de l'énergie puisque
c'est la fin de votre question monsieur
Brun nous avons passé l'année dernière à
protéger nos petites entreprises nous
continuerons à le faire et nous
accompagnons en ce moment même des
renégociations de contrats d'énergie
face au drame humain je crois que les
vociférations ne font pas le poids
madame panot merci de grâce respecter la
mémoire de cet homme qui s'est donné la
mort hier merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur Brun madame la
secrétaire d'État vos diversions ne
trompent personne nous avons dans
l'ensemble nos circonscriptions des
boulangers qui viennent nous voir tous
les jours avec des factures de 5000
euros 10000 euros 15000 euros qui ont
fait x 5 x 14 le Sénat votera cet
automne cette proposition de loi contre
vous contre votre impuissance contre
votre indifférence
merci beaucoup la parole
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Laurence Petel
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente
ma question s'adresse ma question
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Affaires étrangères et j'ai
associé mes collègues du groupe d'amitié
France Arménie pour les Arméniens
l'histoire semble être un éternel
recommencement après le blocus et la
famine sont venus les bombes après les
bombes vient aujourd'hui l'exode pour
échapper au massacre voici le sort des
Arméniens du haut Karaba assiégés depuis
10 mois par l'Azerbaïdjan contraint à ne
manger qu'un repas par jour et qui ces
dernières semaines ont subi l'assaut des
soldats et des bombardements Algérie
malgré deux décisions de la Cour
internationale de Justice exigeant
l'ouverture du corridor de la Chine
malgré les efforts diplomatiques de la
France et des États-Unis auxquels
séjours récemment l'Allemagne il amaliev
qui cultive une haine ancestrale pour
son voisin poursuit son funeste
objective en finir avec les Arméniens et
demain obtenir par la force un corridor
au sud vers le nakishevan la République
d'Arménie qui s'apprête à accueillir des
des dizaine de milliers de réfugiés
doivent aussi faire face à une tentative
de déstabilisation interne cette jeune
démocratie est en danger ces frontières
souveraines menacées Emmanuel Macron
dimanche soir en réaffirmant son soutien
inconditionnel aux Arméniens a également
rappelé sa vigilance absolue au respect
de l'intégrité territoriale du pays la
communauté internationale doit être
lucide les promesses d'un tyran sont des
leurs des stratégies pour gagner du
temps
l'Azerbaïdjan avec le soutien de la
Turquie est désormais la complicité de
la Russie a lancé une guerre de conquête
dans le Caucase du Sud madame la
ministre que peut la diplomatie face à
un tyran qui ne comprend que le rapport
de force et piétine le droit
international en avril vous avez vu à
djermouk les positions azerbaïdjanaises
ont territoire Arméniens aujourd'hui
pour protéger l'Arménie et la démocratie
il nous faut agir sans délai nous
souhaitons que la France prenne
l'initiative d'une action humanitaire
d'ampleur pour aider l'Arménie à
accueillir les réfugiés que la France et
l'un ion européenne s'engagent dans un
ensemble de sanctions contre le clan
Alif qu'une présence internationale soit
employée pour garantir à l'Arménie la
protection de ses frontières les
Arméniens ont droit je vous remercie
madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères et de l'Europe Catherine
Colonna
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
peut-elle vous évoquez un sujet
douloureux et je voudrais commencer par
dire notre émotion et notre tristesse
suite à l'exclosion intervenue hier soir
près de Stéphane adkerque la France est
en contact à ce sujet avec les autorités
arméniennes et l'on verra dans les
prochaines heures du matériel d'urgence
à Erevan pour aider au traitement des
blessés les plus graves cette décision
est prise madame la députée
cette accident dramatique intervient en
effet alors que des milliers d'Arméniens
fuient leur foyer après l'intervention
militaire déclenchée par l'Azerbaïdjan
le 19 septembre à l'issue de neuf mois
plus de 9 mois maintenant de blocus
blocus imposé à des civils en violation
du droit international et cet incident
vient souligner le caractère extrêmement
grave de ce qui se joue le président de
la République l'a dit et ceux qui se
joue se joue aussi sous le regard
complice de la Russie la France a
aussitôt condamné cette intervention
militaire elle a aussitôt demandé et
obtenue une nouvelle réunion du Conseil
de sécurité et demande à l'Azerbaïdjan
de respecter le droit international de
respecter ses engagements de respecter
le droit des populations arméniennes à
vivre chez elle en paix en sécurité dans
le respect de leur histoire et de leur
culture alors nous n'accepterons pas
madame la députée que l'aide humanitaire
soit entravée et nous nous opposerons à
tentative de remise en cause de
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Arménie la
France prendra donc dans les jours qui
viennent des initiatives comme il le
faut que ce soit à titre national à
titre bilatéral avec l'Arménie que ce
soit aux Nations Unies en qualité de
membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité ou que ce soit au sein de
l'Union européenne et par ailleurs nous
porterons aussi à plus de 12 millions
d'euros cette année l'aide que notre
pays apporte au réfugiés et aux déplacés
en Arménie et au Karaba je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame evaçage pour le
groupe écologiste merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique
nous attendions depuis juillet les
annonces du président sur la
planification écologique nous attendions
un moratoire sur les projets
autoroutiers a commencé par l'arrêt du
funeste projet de la 69 nous attendions
une loi de programmation de la
transition écologique comme vous l'avez
fait pour la recherche la justice ou les
armées nous espérions l'augmentation de
l'éco-contribution sur les billets
d'avion au final nous avons eu des
formules de com et une stratégie
illisible il y a une planification mais
il n'y a pas de plan il y a des
objectifs mais il n'y a pas de moyens il
y a une méthode mais il n'y a pas de
volonté politique vous ne pouvez pas en
même temps défendre les transports
collectifs et la bagnole comme vous
dites vous ne pouvez pas en même temps
soutenir le ferroviaire et céder devant
le lobby aérien vous ne pouvez pas
réduire les moyens des collectivités
locales
leur demander de financer les RER
métropolitains le en même temps en
matière de transition écologique ça ne
marche pas et votre hésitation est
irresponsable les écologistes ont
présenté hier un plan de financement de
la transition écologique documenté
progressif et financé nous avons analysé
tous les rapports que vous avez
vous-même commandé le rapport du coi les
rapports philizo Gontard et bien sûr
Pisany ferry leur constats sont clairs
et convergents il faut mettre 13,9
milliards d'euros sur la table dès 2024
et monter à 31 milliards d'euros en 2030
et nous vous avons proposé un
financement de ce plan par l'extinction
progressive des niches fiscales néfastes
au climat et l'imposition exceptionnelle
des plus riches nous prenons nos
responsabilités parce qu'il y a urgence
et si nous portons aujourd'hui les
warming Stripes qui illustrent
l'accélération du réchauffement
climatique c'est pour vous le rappeler
solennellement mes chers collègues vous
savez que vous n'avez pas
votre nouvelle
c'est contraire à l'instruction générale
du bureau mes chers collègues je vous
invite s'il vous plaît à cette série
immédiatement madame la Présidente
Chatelain madame la Présidente
je vous remercie nous avons rappelé ce
matin en conférence des présidents que
nos débats devaient être respectueux de
nos institutions des Français et de nos
règles et je compte sur chacun d'entre
vous pour respecter ce que nous nous
sommes dit ce matin
[Applaudissements]
madame sas
de terminer c'est bon allez allez
terminez votre question s'il vous plaît
notre attitude est respectueux et nous
reposons une question simple quand
allez-vous enfin doter la France d'une
grande loi de programmation de la
transition écologique je vous remercie
madame SAS alors s'il vous plaît je vous
demanderai de remettre les vêtements qui
couvraient ce t-shirt vous n'avez pas à
manifester par votre habillement une
quelconque opinion dans cette émission
alors
je suis contrainte
soit vous respectez nos règles soit je
vous rappelle à l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie
je ne veux plus voir cela pendant la
session qui s'ouvre
[Applaudissements]
on pose à tous il s'impose à tous
je vais donner la parole à Monsieur
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
allez
madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs
les députés
je comprends
que pour ne pas parler du fond vous
choisissiez la forme et un espèce de
happning Pascal la vérité madame SAS au
lieu de vous réfugier derrière des
formules toutes faites vous devriez à la
fois reconnaître le travail qui a été
fait mais on peut pas en même temps
critiquer la proposition du gouvernement
et dans le même temps être confronté la
réalité on peut pas avoir été comme vous
député de 2012 à 2017 quand la France
baissait ses émissions seulement de 1%
et voir qu'aujourd'hui nous avons plus
que doublé ce rythme de baisse des
émissions on peut pas continuer à être
dans une posture qui laisse penser que
pour réussir la transition écologique
dans ce pays on ne peut pas être
écologiste si on n'est pas de gauche on
peut pas en même temps taper sur le
nucléaire et expliquer qu'il faut
accélérer la baisse des émissions on
peut pas à la fois penser que c'est la
solution ce serait taxée d'interdire et
penser qu'à la fin on réussira mobiliser
un pays qu'est-ce qui a été présenté
hier un an de travail une accélération
dans le domaine de la rénovation
dans le domaine des transports dans la
continuité de ce qui a été fait en
matière de vélo un doublement des
surfaces bio un nouveau pacte avec les
territoires une capacité à accélérer à
démontrer une exemplarité publique bref
une stratégie qui est unique au monde
qu'aucun pays n'a pour le moment déployé
une stratégie qui n'a pas d'équivalent
dans les pays où les écologistes sont en
responsabilité alors je comprends mais
l'écologie mérite mieux que des postures
ou des happnings pendant la séance des
questions au Gouvernement elle mérite
mieux qu'une radicalité qui se
confondrait avec la brutalité et
nécessite de la complexité est nécessite
de la nuance elle n'hésite pour
remporter l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
de prendre des décisions de les voter
les rendre applicables c'est l'honneur
de cette majorité c'est le travail qui a
été accompli et c'est l'explication qui
commencera à partir de demain dans la
phase de territorialisation merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame ma nièce car elle
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
ministre l'éducation en zone rurale a
été définie comme une priorité par le
Président de la République et sur ce
sujet nous sommes presque tous concernés
le gouvernement a lancé un plan national
au printemps pour soutenir nos écoles
rurales plantes très attendues par les
parents et les élus deux chiffres sont
très parlants aujourd'hui 9 des 10
départements les plus touchés par les
difficultés de lecture des jeunes sont
des départements ruraux et un
établissement scolaire à deux fois moins
de chances d'être en Rep s'il est situé
en zone rurale que si les situées en
zone urbaine en conséquence les
difficultés scolaires ne sont pas
l'apanage des enfants des métropoles
comme je l'ai écrit en tant que
rapporteur de la mission parlementaire
chargé de dresser un bilan et panorama
de l'éducation prioritaire en France
pourtant les écoles les élèves de ces
écoles sont essentielles pour résorber
la fracture territoriale et redynamiser
nos territoires ne serait-il pas
judicieux de faire bénéficier ces écoles
des programmes de l'éducation
prioritaire dans les mêmes conditions
que se des grandes villes ne faut-il pas
revoir complètement la carte de
l'éducation pour prioritaire afin de
maintenir les moyens renforcés pour les
réplus pourquoi ne pas élargir les aides
à tous les établissements y compris ceux
en zone rurale en indexant aux IPS des
critères sociaux et d'éloignement pour
garantir l'égalité des conditions
d'enseignement sur tout notre territoire
nous pourrions lancer les Assises
nationales de l'éducation prioritaire
pour débattre de l'avenir de tous nos
établissements il est temps de redéfinir
des critères d'aide et d'accompagnement
pour y inclure les établissements ruraux
qui en ont besoin monsieur le ministre
quels sont les dispositions que vous
entendez prendre dans ce domaine merci
je vous remercie la parole la parole est
à Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Agnès Carrel madame la députée l'école
de la République elle ne fait pas de tri
elle ne fait pas de hiérarchie elle fait
la même promesse à tous les élèves de
France celle de bénéficier des mêmes
chances pour réussir pour voir son
niveau s'élevé pour être en capacité de
construire sa vie
et oui ça veut dire que nous devons
mettre davantage de moyens pour
certaines écoles et pour certains
territoires évidemment les quartiers
politiques de la ville mais aussi les
territoires ruraux parce que nous savons
que les élèves de ces territoires
rencontres davantage de difficultés que
les autres vous avez commis un rapport
extrêmement important sur l'éducation a
prioritaire et nous avons déjà un
certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
prises sur ce sujet vous le savez la
première ministre c'est particulièrement
engagé à fait des annonces avant l'été
des annonces qui seront tenues elle a
pris un engagement ferme et inédit
aucune fermeture de classe inopinée ou
non consortée concerté grâce à une
visibilité sur trois ans nous sommes en
train de construire les modalités qui
nous permettront de donner cette
visibilité partager avec les élus pour
être capable de regarder sur du long
terme et de sortir de situations nous
avons des fermetures inopinées sur une
année
dans la droite ligne de cette ambition
nous allons continuer à augmenter nos
moyens pour conserver un taux
d'encadrement qui est très généralement
plus élevé que celui que nous
connaissons ailleurs nous allons
construire 3000 nouvelles places
d'internats d'excellence qui
s'ajouteront au 8000 places déjà
existantes et oui nous allons continuer
à renforcer les moyens des écoles
rurales notamment celles qui souffrent
le plus de l'éloignement et dont les
élèves soufflent le plus de
l'éloignement c'est notamment ce que
nous allons faire avec les territoires
éducatifs ruraux qui permettent un
accompagnement pédagogique et éducatif
renforcés dans votre département de
Seine-Maritime c'est 18150 élèves qui en
bénéficient à cette rentrée nous allons
continuer à construire des dispositifs
en faveur des écoles rurales et je sais
que nous y travaillerons ensemble madame
la députée merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
madame Karel je ne sais pas merci
monsieur le ministre vous avez déjà pris
en compte beaucoup de sujets et merci à
vous nous comptons évidemment sur vous
pour résorber également les les
fractures territoriales merci Merci
beaucoup ma chère collègues il lui
restait 11 secondes
la parole est à Madame angélique rentre
pour le rassemblement national
madame la Présidente chers collègues
monsieur le ministre de l'économie
cette rentrée coûte bien cher aux
Français 11,3% de hausse des coûts des
fournitures scolaires si seulement cela
ne se cantonnait qu'au crayon et au
cahiers mais l'inflation grimpe et le
pouvoir d'achat des Français diminuent
et sur ce dernier point vous êtes les
grands fautifs
votre essence proposition de revente à
perte de carburant transformée en
précoutant des montres d'ailleurs la
déconnexion totale du gouvernement les
distributeurs l'ont d'ailleurs refusé
mais rassurez-vous les Français ne
furont pas s'ils ne peuvent plus prendre
leur voiture le train non plus avez-vous
seulement conscience de l'augmentation
démesurée du prix du billet
cette rentrée c'est finalement un énième
confinement pour les Français à la seule
différence qui ne craignent plus la
covid mais la ruine quant aux factures
d'électricité d'énergie les tarifs
régulés de l'électricité ont augmenté de
10% ce premier août pour les
particuliers mais également pour les
petites entreprises factures qui je le
rappelle ont quand même plus que doublé
depuis 2021 du fait de votre obstination
acceptez le mode européen de fixation
des prix de l'électricité sans ces
règles contraire aux intérêts de la
France Les Français vers et leurs
facturer annuel baisser en moyenne 500
euros
monsieur le ministre que répondez-vous
aux Français qui manquent en moyenne de
588 euros pour renouer avec les loisirs
et une vie globalement plus confortable
et à ceux qui ne peuvent plus se
déplacer se chauffer souffler un peu et
construire leur avenir des samans ne
croyez-vous pas qu'ils soient enfin tant
d'écouter les propositions du
rassemblement national
réformer les règles européennes de
fixation des prix de l'électricité
baisser la TVA sur les énergies produits
de première nécessité libérez les
entreprises sur les augmentations de
salaire en exonérant les charges
salariales ou encore contrôler
drastiquement les groupes qui font
flamber les prix sous couvert de
l'inflation je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
madame la députée angélique je ne crois
sincèrement pas que les solutions du
rassemblement national soient les bonnes
contre l'inflation
[Musique]
l'inflation elle est tirée vous le savez
comme moi par les prix de l'énergie les
prix du gaz et les prix du pétrole
baisser la TVA sur les prix du pétrole
c'est tout simplement alimenter la
consommation d'énergie fossiles c'est
faire la politique de producteurs nous
ne sommes pas producteurs de pétrole
votre proposition de baisse de la TVA
sur l'essence c'est 10 milliards d'euros
c'est le prix d'un réacteur nucléaire et
bien avec cette majorité nous préférons
investir dans l'énergie nucléaire et
dans l'indépendance énergétique du pays
que de financer la politique de
restriction de production des pays
producteurs
nous voulons aussi aider ceux qui
travaillent nous allons mettre en place
une indemnité carburant transport elle
sera mise en place et j'espère que vous
la voterez au 1er janvier 2024 100 euros
par véhicule soit une économie de 20
centimes d'euro par litre de carburant
pour tous ceux qui travaillent les
distributeurs ou les recevront tout à
l'heure avec la première ministre je
suis convaincu qu'ils sont engageront à
offrir de l'essence à prix coûtant pour
les consommateurs comme Total s'est
engagé à plafonner à 1,99 € le prix du
carburant dans les stations services le
combat contre l'inflation c'est un
combat de tous les jours un combat qui
ne mobilise avec Olivia Grégoire avec le
ministre de l'Industrie sans cesse nous
obtenons des résultats nous continuerons
à mener ce combat je ne crois pas aux
solutions de court terme durant national
les nôtres qui visent l'indépendance
énergétique de la nation et avoir des
prix de l'électricité qui sont fondées
sur le coût de production moyen de nos
réacteurs nucléaires nous paraissent les
seules solutions viable sur le long
terme
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame la députée
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre des dispositifs en
faveur de pouvoir d'achat vous avez déjà
proposé aujourd'hui les Français sont
dans la même situation
l'inflation est là le pouvoir d'achat
n'a pas augmenté
très sincèrement si les mouchoirs ne
coûtaient pas aussi cher j'en utiliserai
pour pleurer
la parole est à Madame
hanstonbach Terrenoire pour le groupe
LFI
merci madame la Présidente l'écologie à
la française une écologie qui n'est pas
dans le déni mais qui évacue de force
Thomas braille trop voyant dans l'arbre
devant le ministère pour dénoncer
l'écosystère autoroute a69 l'écologie à
la française une écologie de progrès
aussi parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut
déployer un dispositif de 200 gendarmes
deux hélicoptères des drones et un
arrêté de chasse mensonger pour abattre
des arbres centenaires magnifiques
réserves de biodiversité tout ça au beau
milieu de la nuit devant les larmes
impuissantes de ceux qui les
protégeaient depuis si longtemps
objectif détruire vite avant que la
justice ne puisse se prononcer sur les
recours déposés c'était avantine en
Haute-Garonne le 1er septembre et Thomas
Braille est entré en grève de la fin
puis Olga Bernard Victoria et d'autres
ils sont 14 aujourd'hui rendez-vous
compte dans notre pays il est tellement
impossible de se faire entendre face à
la destruction du vivant et l'urgence
écologique que des gens mettent leur
propre vie dans la balance parce qu'on a
beau manifesté par qui est signé des
pétitions argumentées on est toujours
face à un mur mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire ce projet d'autoroute il a été
pensé il y a 30 ans il est archaïque et
inutile il va seulement détruire près de
400 hectares de presque de terres
agricoles bétonner des espèces protégées
à sécher de précieuses zones tout ça
pour longer la nationale existante en
espérant gagner quelques minutes c'est
absurde 200 scientifiques unanimes dont
deux du GIEC vous demande d'arrêter ce
massacre mais comment oser parler
planification écologique et défendre
cette aberration monsieur le ministre
bonne quand tout sera détruit quand la
terre sera trop sèche pour abriter la
vie que direz-vous à nos enfants qui
pouvait prédire allez-vous enfin stopper
ces travaux laissez la justice se
prononcer et réfléchir à l'alternative
avec les citoyens allez-vous pour une
fois privilégiez le vivant aux intérêts
financiers de quelques-uns ou bien ou
bien laisserez-vous Thomas braille et
ses compagnons de lutte mourir avec les
arbres que vous avez abattu
je vous remercie ma chère collègue la
parole est à monsieur Clément bonne
Vénus en charge de transport
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députés
sont bactérien
ne vous en déplaise nous sommes dans une
démocratie et dans un état de droit vous
avez le droit d'être contre ce projet de
taureaude vous avez le droit de le dire
vous avez le droit de manifester
[Musique]
dans notre pays je sais aussi
[Applaudissements]
que vous êtes parfois un peu plus nuancé
et qu'on doit être attaché à la vérité
vous ne pouvez pas dire n'importe quoi
sur le contenu de ce projet oui il y a
des armes qui seront défricher et coupés
c'est vrai comme pour tous les projets y
compris ferroviaire dans ce pays 5 fois
plus seront replantés vous m'avez remis
en main propre une alternative à ce
projet que j'ai examiné je vous ai
répondu il y aurait dans votre
alternative 7 fois plus cette fois plus
d'arbres coupés madame la députée que
dans le projet qui aujourd'hui porté
enfin Madame le député je le dis avec
gravité et solennité dans cette
hémicycle quel que soit ses opinions
quel que soit sa sensibilité politique
quand on est un responsable politique on
ne met pas la vie d'une personne en
danger on ne pousse pas une personne au
martyrs et j'en veux énormément à ceux
qui ont poussé monsieur braille à
l'excès et il était de notre
responsabilité je l'assume d'avoir une
intervention de protection pour protéger
la santé et la vie faire le contraire
s'appelle non-assistance à personne en
danger
la parole est à Monsieur Hubert hot pour
le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
solidarités et des familles madame la
ministre il est des dates que le nom que
l'on ne peut oublier c'est le cas du
mercredi 9 août 2023 et du violon
incendie qui s'est déclaré à viltzenheim
dans un gîte accueillant des personnes
en situation de handicap mental
originaire notamment de Nancy et de
Lorraine
malgré la mobilisation maximale et sans
faille de nos pompiers des forces de
l'ordre et des services de l'État 10
personnes venu passer des vacances
adaptées ainsi qu'un de leurs
accompagnateurs
Thibault Roth jeune homme de 33 ans on
tragiquement perdu la vie
aujourd'hui encore nous avons tous ici
une pensée particulière pour leur
famille
cette incendie meurtrier qui a frappé
durement l'Alsace et la Lorraine à
bouleversé la France entière la
mobilisation du gouvernement sur place a
été immédiate avec la présence de madame
la Première ministre votre présence
madame la ministre et celle de la
ministre délégué chargé les personnes
handicapées aux côtés des associations
Lorraine concernées ce drame est double
fiscaux de la tragédie que représente ce
très lourd bilan en perte de vie humaine
il est d'autant plus insupportable qui
touche le monde du handicap celui des
associations des structures sociales et
médico-sociales et des aidants celles et
ceux qui au quotidien accompagnent les
personnes en situation de handicap afin
de leur permettre de jouir des mêmes
droits que l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
comme vous vous y étiez engagés vous
avez publié madame la ministre les
conclusions du rapport d'enquête de
l'IGAS que vous aviez demandé sur les
circonstances du drame aussi au regard
de ce rapport et de la succession des
défaillances dont il fait état quelle
mesure allez vous prendre pour éviter
qu'une telle tragédie ne se reproduise
et parce que cette solidarité entre nos
sites merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
je demande vraiment de tâcher de
respecter les deux minutes pour les
questions et pour les réponses madame la
ministre des Solidarités des familles
madame Aurore berger vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député
uberaute vous l'avez dit il y a des
dates qui malheureusement marquent par
la tragédie qu'elles ont emporté le 9
août dernier à wittenham ce sont 10
personnes en situation de handicap et un
accompagnant qui sont décédés dans des
conditions absolument tragiques dans un
incendie d'un gîte je veux ici rendre
hommage à l'engagement sans faille des
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont tout fait pour
tenter d'arrêter ce drame
immédiatement avec la première ministre
le jour même sur place le lendemain avec
la ministre délégué aux personnes
handicapées auprès des associations et
des familles nous sommes évidemment
rendus sur place et nous avons
immédiatement en parallèle de l'enquête
judiciaire diligente et une inspection
de gaz et nous avons rendu public les
conclusions ligaques qui étaient la
moindre des choses vis-à-vis des
personnes décédées vis-à-vis des
familles cette inspection de l'IGAS elle
montre en vérité des défaillances
généralisées sur la question dite des
vacances adaptées organisées ces
vacances qui sont celles des personnes
en situation de handicap des vacances
qui sont celles aussi des aidants qui
accèdent grâce à elle à durépie ils
disons le très clairement il n'est pas
question qu'il y ait du business qui
soit fait sur le dos des personnes en
situation de handicap sur le dos de leur
famille et qui ne garantissent pas la
qualité d'accueil des personnes et la
sécurité de l'accueil des personnes dès
cette semaine nous enverrons une
instruction à l'ensemble des
prestataires des vacances adaptés de
manière à ce qu'il remplit son fin leur
condition de sécurité et à des services
déconcentrés de l'État de manière à ce
que tous les agréments délivrés et tous
les agréments délivrés à l'avenir valide
les conditions de sécurité notamment sur
les questions sécurité incendies ce qui
n'avait pas été le cas pour vite ce name
et pour l'organisme malheureusement
concerné nous devons aller plus loin
pour diffuser une véritable culture du
contrôle nous devons aux personnes
handicapées la capacité qu'elles ont à
partir en vacances à avoir accès aux
loisirs partout dans notre pays et avec
des vacances adaptées quand c'est
nécessaire mais pas au prix de leur
sécurité monsieur le député merci
beaucoup madame la ministre non vous
n'avez plus de temps monsieur le
Président Marley juste avant de vous
donner la parole je voudrais saluer
monsieur Fabien daphilippo parce que
tout à l'heure j'ai salué le 15
parlementaires et il a gagné le
championnat de France de course cycliste
des élus il a été double mais d'ailleurs
et donc je pense qu'on peut le saluer
également
[Applaudissements]
s'il y a d'autres sportifs dans les
musiques qu'il se signale pour que je
puisse les saluer également monsieur le
Président Marley pour le groupe les
républicains
[Musique]
possible de ne jamais apprendre de ses
erreurs après Alstom Alcatel technique
nous voilà donc à la veille d'un nouvel
abandon de souveraineté industrielle
avec le démembrement projeté du géant
des services numériques Atos qui emploie
je le rappelle 50000 personnes dans
notre pays une fois de plus les
liquidateurs de l'industrie française
sont à la manave se partageant nous
dit-on déjà quelques centaines de
millions d'euros de commissions et
d'honoraires ce qui est finalement pas
mal pour une entreprise qui est
soi-disant au pied du mur une fois de
plus on nous racontera katos est une
entreprise privée qu'il faut laisser
faire ce serait oublier katos n'est pas
une création spontanée du marché elle
est l'héritière de la volonté politique
du général de Gaulle de la France de
supercalculateurs indispensable à notre
dissuasion nucléaire elle est
l'héritière de bulles qui a des
bénéficié de centaines de millions
d'euros de commandes publiques de
recherche publique par le CEA ou par le
ministère des armées Atos c'est la seule
entreprise européenne capable de
fabriquer des supercalculateurs
indispensables dans le monde de
l'intelligence artificielle elle héberge
aussi les données sensibles de nombreux
ministères elle est enfin au cœur de
votre stratégie France 2030 sur le futur
ordinateur quantique certes Atos a perdu
la confiance des marchés et 90% de sa
valeur mais elle est rentable et rien
rien ne justifie la précipitation votre
gouvernement est-il donc prêt madame la
Première ministre à intervenir pour
sauvegarder cet acteur majeur de notre
souveraineté industrielle
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président Olivier marlex
vous avez souligné avec force
l'importance du dossier Atos
cette conviction je la pâte partage
totalement c'est un enjeu de
souveraineté essentiel pour notre pays
c'est pour cela que nous suivons ce
sujet avec la plus grande attention nous
sommes en particulier très attentifs à
ce que les activités sensibles
rassembler dans l'entité Atos BDS
dispose des moyens nécessaires pour
poursuivre leur développement au sein
d'une organisation qui assure la
protection de nos intérêts je pense en
particulier à l'activité des
supercalculateurs
l'opération de rachat en cours concerne
take Foundation c'est-à-dire la branche
d'Atos spécialisée dans l'Info gérance
l'examen des différentes offres relèvent
du conseil d'administration donc une
société privée dans l'état n'est pas
actionnaire mais même si l'opération
était menée à son terme elle n'aurait
aucune insulte aucune incidence en
termes de contrôle ou de droite blocage
sur les activités sensibles pour de
telles activités je rappelle que si une
entité étrangère veut monter au capital
d'une entreprise française cela
nécessite une autorisation du ministre
de l'économie au titre du contrôle des
investissements étrangers à cet égard
notre pays est aujourd'hui mieux armé
pour défendre sa souveraineté depuis six
ans nous avons considérablement renforcé
les dispositifs de contrôle des
investissements étrangers en France nous
avons abaissé le seuil de déclenchement
des contrôles nous avons étendu à de
nouveaux secteurs stratégiques comme
l'intelligence artificielle les semis
conducteurs ou la cryptographie résultat
entre 2017 et 2022 le nombre de
contrôles a plus que doublé monsieur le
Président marlex je peux vous assurer
que nous défendons les intérêts
stratégiques de notre pays concernant
Atos nous restons très vigilants à ce
que nos intérêts souverains soient
préservés en toute circonstances je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre monsieur le Président
Marleix
j'ai le sentiment que vous avez déjà
acté la scission de l'entreprise nous
parlons de texte
n'est pas le rôle des banquiers
d'affaires d'imaginer l'avenir de cette
entreprise c'est le rôle de l'État c'est
même réagir son devoir
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq
pour le groupe GDF merci madame la
Présidente avec les putsch au Niger au
Gabon cet été votre politique
néocoloniale et impérialiste en Afrique
a connu l'un des plus grands revers la
faute à une politique pilotée pour nos
intérêts économiques de l'uranium au
pétrole de même ce même fait colonial
qui est dénoncé dans nos outre-mer
qui vivent la persistance de cette
mentalité dans des territoires exploités
uniquement pour leurs ressources
naturelles sans égard pour la souffrance
des populations au risque d'une
explosion sociale que vous ne saurez pas
avoir venir vous savez vous avez demandé
aux militaires de faire de l'humanitaire
aux humanitaires vous leur avez demandé
de faire de la politique au diplomates
vous leur avez demandé de n'être que la
caisse de résonance de l'Élysée et donc
des multinationales françaises et quand
vous prétendez défendre la démocratie
les peuples vous répondent en dénonçant
et en rejetant les tricheurs il n'y a
pas de sentiment anti-français les
peuples africains sont anti-politiques
françaises ils veulent accéder à leur
deuxième indépendance celle de la
souveraineté économique et financière
nous devrions les écouter nous devrions
fermer les bases militaires en Afrique
et en finir avec le français et que dire
du franc pacifique au lieu de cela vous
continuez à exiger des sanctions
internationales qui étouffent les
peuples et renforcent l'image d'une
politique française aveugle aux besoins
des peuples vous avez même exigé la fin
de la coopération naturel avec tous les
artistes maliens burkinabe et nigérien
est bloquer l'obtention des visas pour
les étudiants ressortissants de ces
états en appliquant ces injustes
sanctions collectives vous vous en
prenez aux puissants vecteurs de paix
que sont les coopérations culturelles et
intellectuelles madame Colona et
Monsieur Vigier quand la rogance
néocoloniale va-t-elle quitter nos
politiques publiques
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député le coq il m'arrive d'être
d'accord avec vous j'espère que personne
ne s'en offusque mais là je ne saurais
l'être tant vos propos dépassent la
réalité
au Gabon comme au Niger notre politique
et guidé par les deux principes qui nous
gouvernent toujours 1 nous condamnons
tous les coups d'État 2 nous soutenons
les organisations régionales au Niger la
CEDEAO au Gabon les pays d'Afrique
centrale voilà la réalité et je voudrais
aussi vous rappeler que l'Afrique ne se
réduit pas au Sahel et à quelques jantes
qui remettent en cause la France pour
masquer leur propre échecs ne faites pas
comme Monsieur le Député je vous en prie
bien au contraire les relations entre la
France et la plupart des 54 pays
africains se portent bien ce porte même
très bien en 15 ans le volume de nos
investissements a doublé est un fait nos
universités sont attractives elles
accueillent aujourd'hui
92000 étudiants africains soit 40% de
plus qu'en 2017 c'est un fait nous avons
augmenté nos traits de développement de
50% en 6 ans c'est un fait
tout sur le continent nous menons des
coopérations avec les scientifiques les
jeunesses les sportifs les artistes
monsieur le députés et à propos des
artistes permettez-moi de dire que les
mesures que vous évoquez non jamais ni
été prise ni même n'ont été demandé
et surtout nous traitons l'Afrique
sur un pied d'égalité pour traiter avec
elle les grands défis de demain les
grands enjeux que sont la fin le
développement le climat la santé
mondiale nous soutenons dans la
gouvernance mondiale le poids de
l'Afrique et des pays africains nous le
faisons au G20 nous le faisons conseils
de sécurité l'Union africaine vient
d'entrer au G20 avec notre soutien voilà
la réalité monsieur député et voilà ce
que nous faisons avec nos partenaires
africains je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la ministre monsieur
Lecoq merci madame la Présidente
entendez ce que disent les peuples
africains entendaient les évidemment
c'est pas toute l'Afrique les deux
minutes qui me sont accordés ne me
permettent pas de vous faire la liste
mais vous savez très bien que la partie
CDAO par exemple et bien les anciennes
colonies françaises ont un message à
donner à la France et ce message vous
avez du mal à l'entendre et c'était le
sens de cette question je vous remercie
monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Virginie l'anneau pour le groupe
Renaissance et bienvenue à l'Assemblée
madame la députée merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais vous lire le message qu'une
jeune fille devenue femme a récemment
envoyé à son ancienne camarade il y a
des années de cela j'ai subi de ta part
harcèlement humiliation et attouchement
ces agissements ont bousillé ma vie
d'enfants et d'adolescentes j'ai pu me
reconstruire et construire une famille
formidable mais jamais je n'oublierai
ces heures de souffrance et de détresse
j'ai pensé à une période dénoncer ses
agissements cela fait maintenant plus de
40 ans c'est loin mais un débile
cette jeune fille c'était moi et je ne
crois pas être la seule sur ces bancs à
avoir été victimes de harcèlement
un enfant sur quatre on est victime
combien parlent le harcèlement scolaire
est un drame intime tu enfouis parfois
toute une vie le harcèlement scolaire
est un drame qui porte mal son nom car
il ne s'arrête pas en vérité au mur de
l'école il continue après les cours au
foot ou à la danse il revient par
message ou sur les réseaux sociaux la
nuit il hante les rêves qui deviennent
des cauchemars il a le droit de citer
partout
c'est un drame qui se niche dans
l'anodin une violence qui ne réclame pas
de coup une blessure qui ne se part pas
de sang je voudrais vous lire aussi ces
mots d'enfants qu'il expriment si bien
le harcèlement c'est comme l'uranium ça
brûle de l'intérieur le harcèlement ça
commence par une étincelle ça finit par
un incendie maman ce n'est pas pour rire
que j'ai voulu mourir
j'aurais voulu lire enfin les mots de
tous ceux qui se sont donnés la mort
avant de parler qui avant de parler en
haut du crier dans leur tête mais le
silence les a emportés il n'est rien de
pire que de ne pas parler sauf peut-être
de parler et de ne pas être entendu
Nicolas comme dans d'autres a parlé n'a
pas été entendu en parlant de honte vous
avez mis les mots justes monsieur le
ministre sur la réaction indigne de
notre Académie je sais que vous avez à
coeur que cette réaction partout change
mais pouvez-vous nous dire concrètement
les actes que vous entendez mettre à ces
mots pour partout par tous les combattre
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal min Istre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Virginie Lanaud
Marion 13 ans
et va elle 11 ans Dina 14 ans ambre 11
ans
Lucas 13 ans Thibault 10 ans
Chanel 12 ans Marie 15 ans
l'Insee 13 ans Nicolas 15 ans c'est non
ce sont ceux d'enfants enlevés à leurs
parents
ce sont ceux d'élèves enlevé à leurs
enseignants ce sont ceux de jeunes
enlevés à leur pays par un fléau le
harcèlement scolaire
ce fléau il ne connaît pas de frontières
ce fléau il tue et quand il ne tue pas
par la mort il tue la confiance en soi
de jeunes qui ne demandent qu'à s'aimer
et à aimer les autres
madame la députée j'ai fait des
manominations au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
la lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
ma priorité absolue et je le dis de
manière très claire je ne reculerai
devant rien je ne reculerai devant rien
pour mieux prévenir je ne reculerai
devant rien pour que la peur change de
camp je ne reculerai devant rien pour
que la honte change de camp
nous avons d'ores et déjà commencé à
agir avec des décisions importantes qui
ont été prises cet été sur les sanctions
à l'endroit des harceleurs demain la
première ministre présentera et nous
serons à ses côtés le plan
interministériel de lutte contre le
harcèlement pour aller plus loin mieux
prévenir mieux détecter mieux réagir
nous sommes engagés sur ce sujet nous
avons appelé à un électrochoc et je
constate que l'électrochoc a commencé
oui la peur doit changer de camp oui
nous devons être plus efficaces dans la
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
c'est ce que nous devons à tous les
élèves de France c'est ce que nous
devons à toutes les familles de France
c'est ce que nous devons à l'école de la
République et c'est ce que nous devons à
notre nation merci beaucoup monsieur
menest
la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin Lucas
pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente ce mardi le
président de la République c'est
entretenu à Rome avec la présidente du
Conseil italien l'année offensiste
Georgia Meloni il se reverront vendredi
à Malte alors la France tiendra-t-elle
enfin son rang se montrera-t-elle fidèle
à sa tradition d'accueil à la force
universelle de son message humaniste le
président Macron ça sera-t-il de mentir
en affirmant que l'Europe est le
continent qui je cite fait le plus alors
que l'écrasante majorité des migrations
dans le monde se fait entre pays du Sud
comprendrea-t-il enfin que le
durcissement croissant des conditions
d'accueil des nouveaux arrivants que les
40 000 km de murs construits pendant le
jeûne 21e siècle ne produisent que deux
effets que deux seuls effets
l'enrichissement des passeurs et
l'augmentation du nombre de cadavres
englouti dans la Méditerranée
comprendre et vous que nous ne
connaissons pas de crise migratoire de
submersion ou d'invasion comme le
prétend l'extrême droite et qu'au total
les migrations ne concernent que 3,5% de
la population mondiale mais que 30 ans
de politique répressives ont créé une
crise de fraternité une crise de
l'accueil à laquelle doit répondre une
politique ambitieuse de l'inclusion
notamment en garantissant le droit à la
scolarisation des mineurs non
accompagnés dont l'UNICEF nous dit qu'il
est gravement entravé ou encore en
soutenant les humanitaires qui de Calais
à Marseille en passant par Briançon sauf
des vies et je veux leur rendre hommage
ici
entendre et vous ce que vous disent tous
les chercheurs toutes les études tous
les chiffres votre prétendu appelèrent
n'existe pas et notamment pas dû à notre
modèle social que d’ailleurs vous vous
achnez à effriter cessez-vous enfin
d'opposer les souffrances entre ceux qui
fuit les guerres et ceux qui fuit la
misère en clair choisirez-vous la vérité
et la confiance plutôt que le mensonge
la peur
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente de Monsieur
les députés monsieur le député Lucas les
questions migratoires sont des questions
très difficiles parce qu'ils touchent
vous l'avez dit vous-même dans votre
question l'humain et des humains qui
traversent parfois vous le savez des
conditions extrêmement difficiles pour
aller vers la terre qu'ils pensent être
promise en tout cas une terre qui leur
rapporte une protection qu'elle s'agit
d'une protection politique religieuse de
liberté sexuelle ou simplement pour fuir
la famine ou les difficultés climatiques
il est évident que la France a toujours
tenu son rang il y a aujourd'hui
monsieur le député vous le savez 500 000
personnes qui sont protégées par
Lovecraft c'est-à-dire par notre pays
sur le sol national et nous avons entre
100 000 et 130000 demandes d'asile
chaque année et chaque année nous
décisions de les étudier la meilleure
manière possible devant les difficultés
croissantes c'est notamment pour cela
que depuis 2017 nous finançons 123000
par exemple place de demandeurs d'asile
30 000 de plus par rapport à 2018 ce qui
explique que 80% des gens qui demandent
l'asile sont logés bon état et logé par
parler français par leurs impôts
cependant monsieur député de tenir son
rang donné l'asile être au rendez-vous
des questions migratoires ce n'est pas
tout accepté et il faut distinguer et je
crois que ces débats de tout et
démocraties il n'y a pas une démocraties
au monde et même les vers Allemands ont
voté le pacte migratoire et vous devriez
peut-être être un peu solidaire de vos
collègues à laquelle vous avez des
alliances politiques parce que oui il
faut distinguer la personne qui vient
demander l'asile dans notre continent
qui doit être accueilli le mieux
possible le plus rapidement possible
c'est ce que nous portons dans le texte
immigration que j'ai l'honneur de
présenter dans les deux chambres dans
les semaines qui viennent et en même
temps bien sûr qui ne peut pas accepter
toute migration irrégulière illégale qui
n'est pas passé par les cadres légaux en
France on peut migré légalement comme
dans toute l'Europe à l'exception
peut-être de la Grande-Bretagne les
interviendront et donc nous devons aussi
accepter qu'on ne peut pas sans critères
prendre toutes les personnes qui veulent
venir sur le sol européen par défaut de
capacité d'intégration en effet donc
dans votre question je crois qu'il y
avait une partie de la réponse oui la
France tient sa part non la France ne
peut pas prendre toute la part de tous
les autres merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur Lucas
chemise de l'intérieur la France est
grande quand elle porte un message de
fraternité de générosité et d'accueil
décidément le macronisme restera comme
quelque chose de tout tout petit
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Estelle Youssoupha pour le groupe yote
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
parce que c'est ici l'action de son
gouvernement que je questionne demain
matin madame Mayotte sera dans la rue
pour hurler de soif pour vous rappeler
que nous survivons à peine sans eau vous
rappeler que l'accès à l'eau potable est
un droit que vous devez nous garantir à
Mayotte nous n'avons que quelques heures
d’eau tous les deux trois jours une eau
que la rsoptine a répété potable mais
qu'il faut faire bouillir avant de
consommer une eau puante marron mais
potable la RS de Mayotte n'a-t-elle donc
rien appris des scandales sanitaires le
pack d'eau ce ventre 5 et 12 euros à
Mayotte pour une famille de quatre
personnes c'est au minimum 6 bouteilles
par jour soit un budget d'environ 300
euros par mois alors que votre
gouvernement distribue des chèques
carburant quand mettez-vous en place un
chèque eau pour Mayotte quand
effacez-vous les factures d'eau que les
Maoré reçoivent par
ce que l'air fait tourner l'eau des
compteurs
le gouvernement a distribué 600 000
bouteilles d'eau pour les plus
vulnérables je vous dis merci mais quid
du reste de la population sans eau tous
les maorets ne sont-ils pas tous
vulnérables parlons du risque de
typhoïde et de choléra sur notre île qui
compte de nombreux bidons villes la
crise sanitaire est imminente alors que
notre seul hôpital s'effondre avec une
centaine de soignants qui manquent à la
pelle dans le plus grand désert médical
de France nos écoles nous lycées ferment
faute d'eau dans des robinets ou à cause
de la violence qui a repris parce que ou
en bouchon est suspendu quid de la
scolarité de nos enfants pourquoi ne
profitez-vous pas de la sécheresse pour
nettoyer les rivières et les retenues
colinaires pour clôturer nos réservoirs
d'eau pourquoi n'avez-vous pas commandé
des citernes pour équiper tous les
foyers maorés combien de temps Mayotte
peut-elle tenir dans l'état actuel des
coupures et des réserves d'eau
Mayotte est en train de basculer en
enfer le préfet dépassé ma question
votre gouvernement a-t-il démissionné à
Mayotte sommes-nous nous mahorés sortis
de la République quant à les voiliers à
hauteur de cette crise et de la
République je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Bugey
ministre délégué aux outre-mer merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur député
madame le député la situation de Mayotte
vous l'avez décrite inédite elle est
gravement et avec le gouvernement je
peux vous dire que nous sommes
totalement mobilisés autour de la
première ministre de Gérald Darmanin et
je tiens à dire ici que cette crise
madame la députée elle exige d'être à la
hauteur des enjeux tout d'abord vous
l'avez rappelé le préfet du prendre des
mesures drastiques du réduction de l'eau
deux jours sur 3 c'est-à-dire que les
malheureuses et les mahorés qui font
preuve d'une résilience formidable en de
l'eau un jour sur trois deuxièmement
nous avons fait quoi nous avons mis en
place qu'on appelle des chemins de l'eau
pour sécuriser les écoles les services
publics et les établissements de santé
nous avons mis en place des vous le
savez dans chaque dans chacune des
communes en accord avec les élus qu'on
appelle des Rambos pour pouvoir apporter
de l'eau là où il n'y en a pas nous
avons apporté pour les écoles pour 38
écoles c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas d'eau
des bonbonnes de 2000 litres de manière
à ce qu'on puisse apporter aux enfants
de l'eau sanitaire
ça ne suffit pas vous l'avez rappelé
madame le député et je tiens à dire du
bon la présentation nationale que grâce
à vous nous avons élargi le public de
celles et ceux qui bénéficient de
bouteilles d'eau ce sont pas 600 000
bouteilles mais 5 millions 400 000
bouteilles d'eau qui ont été commandées
et je dis si cela ne manque les morts et
les éléments auraient que nous
souhaitons les plus protégés auront des
bouteilles d'eau jusqu'à ce que la crise
soit résolue il ne restons pas là 35
millions d'euros sont engagés
immédiatement pour faire ce qu'on
appelle un schéma de connexion de
potable pour
colmater les fuites parce qu'il y a
énormément de filles dans les réseaux
mahorés nous sommes à côté des aiguilles
locaux la Légion est mobilisée le
ministre de l'Intérieur ce matin a
décidé de mobiliser la sécurité civile
les armées leçons avec le service
militaire adaptés les élus ne sont avec
les centres communaux de l'action
sociale bref nous sommes tous sur le
pont et j'annonce enfin que deux usines
de dessalement verront le jour fin 2024
en attendant nous serons à vos côtés
tout le gouvernement immobilisé et sous
leur été l'autorité de la première
ministre et du milieu de l'intérieur
croyez bien que nous serons à vos côtés
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Madame Maud Bregeon pour
le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre des solidarités et des
familles madame la ministre la précarité
qui touche de nombreuses familles
françaises et rarement un hasard social
au contraire elle se transmet d'une
génération à l'autre certains
appelleront ça à signeration à résidence
d'autres déterminent mais le constat est
le même votre enjeu notre enjeu est donc
double aider les Français touchés par la
pauvreté à en sortir plus rapidement et
lutter durablement contre cette
reproduction qui traverse les
générations et touche toutes les sphères
de la vie
si notre modèle social fait partie des
plus robustes et des plus redistributifs
au monde et sans jamais omettre tout ce
qui a été réalisé ces dernières années
pour protéger les Français la réalité
que j'ai décrite précédemment est accrue
par les crises que l'on traverse et
notamment par la crise climatique si la
planète est la même pour tous nous ne
sommes pas tous égaux face au
réchauffement climatique les classes
populaires les familles les plus pauvres
en sont et en seront les premières
victimes parce qu'elles sont les plus
vulnérables face à notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles quand les prix des
factures de gaz et d'électricité grimpe
quand l'accès à l'eau et à une
alimentation saine dès le plus jeune âge
devient plus difficile
qu'on a plus les moyens de sortir de sa
passoire thermique la question
écologique appelle donc et peut-être
avant tout une réponse sociale et
solidaire loin des discours
moralisateurs et inaudibles pour tous
ceux qui vivent déjà dans une sobriété
subie pouvez-vous nous dire concrètement
madame la ministre quelle action
comptez-vous mener pour permettre aux
familles les plus modestes d'y faire
face dans le cadre du Plan solidarité
que vous portez au sein de ce
gouvernement je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la députée la parole est
à Madame Aurore berger ministre des
Solidarités des familles merci merci
madame la Présidente merci madame la
députée de Brégeon je sais l'engagement
qui est le vote sur les enjeux de
transition écologique et énergétiques
vous l'avez rappelé malheureusement la
pauvreté elle se transmet aujourd'hui
dans notre pays de génération en
génération on estime qu'on met en
moyenne 7 générations à sortir de la
pauvreté durablement ce qui signifie que
quand on est pauvre on peut rester
pauvre dans notre pays et c'est bien ça
qu'il faut impérativement briser il faut
le briser avec des enjeux qui sont
structurels la question de l'emploi dans
notre génération ne pensait pas pouvoir
avoir accès aux pleine emploi et lutter
définitivement contre le chômage de
masse c'est aujourd'hui possible et nous
allons y arriver et évidemment il faut
aller plus loin pour faire que le
travail paye c'est tout l'enjeu de la
conférence sociale portée par la
première ministre et par le ministre du
Travail puis vous l'avez dit il y a la
manière avec laquelle la transition
énergétique peut de manière différente
toucher les Français et aujourd'hui on a
une forme de double peine qui touche les
personnes qui sont les plus vulnérables
dans notre pays à la fois elles sont
moins responsables du des règlements
climatiques mais elle le paye plus elle
le paye sur les mobilités elle le paye
sur la précarité énergétique de
l'horlogements elle le paye sur l'accès
à une alimentation durable et de qualité
et c'est ça que nous avons ajouté dans
Le Pacte des solidarités parce que
lutter contre la pauvreté c'est aussi
garantir que la transition écologique et
énergétique elle soit juste et pour
qu'elle soit juste elle doit donc être
solidaire c'est ce que nous faisons avec
le ministre de l'écologie notamment sur
la question de la précarité énergétique
puisqu'on double les moyens justement
pour lutter contre cette précarité
énergétique c'est ce qu'on fait sur la
question du logement en particulier
l'hébergement d'urgence qui est garantie
grâce au Pacte des solidarités avec
203000 hébergement d'urgence c'est ce
qu'on fait sur l'alimentation et je
pense en particulier à nos enfants les
petits déjeuners gratuits les cantines à
1 € permettant une tarification sociale
c'est la garantie que nos enfants
étaient accèdes alimentation saine et de
qualité parce qu'on étudie pas bien si
on étudie le ventre creux donc oui notre
engagement il est total évidemment dans
la lutte contre la pauvreté dans notre
pays je vous remercie je vous remercie
madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur kevin fait
faire du rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre des comptes publics quand vous
avez votre taxe foncière qui augmente
c'est pas le gouvernement c'est votre
commune qui le décide et c'est un
scandale ces mots d'un culot monstre
vous les avez reconnu ce sont ceux du
président Macron un culot monstre au
service du mensonge car la hausse de la
taxe foncière est bel et bien due au
gouvernement dans les 30 000 communes
qui n'ont pas touché à leur taux cette
hausse de 7,1% jamais vu depuis près de
40 ans et dû au choix de ce gouvernement
d'indexer les valeurs locatives sur
l'inflation mesure prise dès votre
arrivée au pouvoir en 2017 et Monsieur
Cazenave où nous avait prévenu il y a
quelques jours ça sera à nouveau plus 5%
pour les propriétaires en 2024 au final
en trois ans seulement les taxes
foncières augmenteront de plus de 16%.
alors bien sûr à cette spoliation
s'ajoute l'augmentation des taux par
certaines communes d'ailleurs si on
pensait que la guerre fiscale à la
France des 34 millions de propriétaires
étaient réservés à la gauche pas de
jaloux il faut les faire passer à la
caisse Paris plus 52% socialiste Meudon
plus 43%
udi Grenoble + 24 % vers Bobigny + 24 %
PCF 3S Courbevoie plus 20% LR et ou en
marche parce qu'on comme toujours on ne
sait plus trop dans ces cas-là mais vous
ne trouverez dans cette liste occulte
des communes gérées par le rassemblement
national après juste les Perpignan les
taux n'ont jamais été augmentés à
Hénin-Beaumont aillange ou Beaucaire les
taux ont même baissé et ceci il faut le
dire malgré la hausse non compensée des
coûts pour nos communes point d'indice
des fonctionnaires mais surtout énergie
et inflation encore de votre
responsabilité nous l'avons proposé lors
du dernier budget un amendement pour
limiter l'augmentation par les communes
de leur taux un autre amendement pour
plafonner à 2% l'augmentation des
valeurs locatives mais vous les avez
rejetées pire vous avez imposé vos choix
par 49,3 alors tout cela monsieur le
ministre et le fruit de choix politiques
nous faisons le choix de la paix fiscale
et de rendre leur argent contribuables
et vous et le président Macron quand
allez-vous cesser de mépriser les élus
locaux et de faire la poche des Français
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Thomas Cazenave ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
monsieur le député je veux le dire
clairement la taxe foncière est une taxe
100 % local
l'Assemblée nationale l'Assemblée
nationale en 2016 a choisi à une immense
majorité l'indexation des bases
foncières sur l'inflation donc ce n'est
pas une décision de ce gouvernement
c'est un choix d'indexer les bases
foncières et sur cette base là les élus
en responsabilité
choisissent d'augmenter les taux de
maintenir les taux ou de baisser les
taux ils ont le choix c'est un impôt
local et en aucune manière
de vous dire que vous ne pouvez pas
expliquer la hausse de la taxe foncière
par la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation qui a été compensée à
l'euro près par les copains pour les
communes et enfin je tiens à vous dire
Monsieur le Député quand vous défendez
un amendement qui vise à plafonner qui
vise à plafonner l'évolution des basses
foncières à 2%. vous privez les
collectivités territoriales de 1,9
milliards d'euros donc deux fois
l'indexation de la DGF que vous réclamez
donc un peu de cohérence monsieur le
député vous avez l'indexation à
géométrie variable un jour vous
l'indexer la taxe la dotation et le
lendemain vous voulez plafonner la taxe
foncière et je dois dire que cesser
d'opposer l'État et les collectivités
territoriales notre méthode c'est le
dialogue et la concertation ne vous en
déplaise monsieur le député parce que
c'est la seule méthode qui marche merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Paul Vanier pour le
groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente abaya pas de
prof voilà monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale la triste réalité
de cette rentrée 3000 postes vacants à
l'issue des concours aux enseignants
1500 postes supprimés au budget de l'an
passé au moins un professeur manquant
dans 50% de nos collèges et de nos
lycéens cette situation a une
explication la crise de recrutement elle
vient principalement de la politique
d'appauvrissement mise en œuvre par
votre gouvernement
depuis 2017 les professeurs de notre
pays ont perdu près de 12% de leur
pouvoir d'achat c'est l'équivalent d'un
mois de salaire en moins chaque année il
y a 40 ans un enseignant en début de
carrière gagner à l'équivalent de deux
SMIC aujourd'hui il débute à 1,2 SMIC
quel autre profession a connu pareil des
classements
mercredi dernier c'est vérité était
exposées par les organisations
syndicales représentatives de
l'éducation nationale reçu en audition
par la commission de l'éducation pour
toute réponse les représentants
enseignants ont reçu une bordée
d'injures venu d'un arc du mépris
courant des macronistes au le pénis
monsieur le ministre vous avez fait
connaître votre intention de comprendre
le fonctionnement de l'école publique et
vous vous préparez à un séjour de
découverte ce rendez-vous en terre
inconnue vous livrera un enseignement
l'école publique comme l'hôpital public
est en voie d'effondrement il faut la
reconstruire en commençant par
reconnaître l'expertise des enseignants
et la valeur sociale de leur métier
assez de Job Dating assez de pacte vides
monsieur le ministre allez-vous
augmenter massivement et sans condition
tous les enseignants afin de garantir le
droit à l'éducation de tous nos enfants
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés Paul Vanier j'étais ce matin
pendant trois heures avec les
organisations syndicales à l'occasion du
Comité Social d'action ministérielle et
on a notamment parlé de la question de
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant et
des rémunérations évidemment qu'il y a
des débats sur l'ampleur des
revalorisations qui ont eu lieu en cette
rentrée mais tous ont reconnu tous ont
reconnu qu'il s'agissait de la plus
forte revalorisation depuis 20 ou 30 ans
dans notre pays la réalité monsieur
Vannier c'est qu'il y a trois ans un
enseignant en début de carrière néo
titulaire gagner 1700 euros net par mois
et quand cette rentrée il gagne 2100
euros net par mois ça fait 400 euros de
plus en 3 ans
vous avez abordé la comparaison avec le
SMIC en l'an 2000 un enseignant en début
de carrière gagnait 1,7 SMIC c'était
tombé à 1,5 SMIC en 2013 en janvier
prochain ce sera 1,8 SMIC nous avons
effacé vingt ans d'effondrement de
rémunération en début de carrière
evidemment il faut continuer à aller
plus loin pour tout le monde d'ailleurs
les revalorisations en cette rentrée
elle concerne tous les enseignants de
manière inconditionnelle chaque
enseignant en cette rentrée gagnent
entre 125 et 250 euros net de plus par
mois qu'à la rentrée 2022 c'est un fait
c'est un fait
il faut continuer à avancer sur la
question de l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant qui évidemment ne se résume
pas à la question salariale mais
concerne aussi la formation initiale les
mobilités les conditions d'exercice et
sur ce sujet là j'ai ouvert un travail
spécifique avec les organisations
syndicales on s'est réuni sur le sujet
un programme de travail a été défini
j'avance avec les organisations
syndicales sur ce sujet formation
initiale déroulement de carrière
mobilité conditions d'exercice oui on
doit agir pour renforcer l'attractivité
du métier d'enseignant ça passe par des
actes concrets s'agissant des
rémunérations et des revalorisations ils
sont au rendez-vous en cette rentrée je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à madame Lise manier pour le
groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
Transports et j'ai associé mon collègue
Xavier Albertini monsieur le ministre ma
question concerne l'autorisation des
camions de 48 tonnes pour le transport
de la betterave sucrière et à ce titre
et elle concerne d'ailleurs tout autant
l'agriculture l'industrie les
collectivités territoriales et la
transition écologique car vous le savez
la filière de la betterave sucrière est
l'une de nos filières agricoles majeures
par son poids économique par sa
participation à notre souveraineté et
par les emplois qu'elle offre sur nos
territoires ruraux cette filière a
souhaité depuis 2019 répondre à la
triple problématique posée par
l'organisation du transport pendant la
campagne betteravière que sont le coût
économique les impacts pour les
habitants de nos territoires ruraux et
l'enjeu de la baisse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre avec depuis deux
ans l'expérimentation du transport par
48 tonnes
le bilan est clairement positif une
réduction des poids lourds sur les
routes d'au moins 10% avec des gains de
productivité associés une réduction
claire de l'empreinte carbone et de
réels avantages en termes de sécurité
routière aucune critique n'a été
formulée sur les résultats de cette
expérimentation dans la méthodologie et
la transparence sont reconnus par
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
pourtant
ni la généralisation ni même la
poursuite de cette expérimentation ne
seront possibles pour la prochaine
campagne betteravière qui s'ouvre dans
quelques semaines faute d'une décision
prise à temps par le comité
interministériel aussi Monsieur le
Ministre comment peut-on expliquer à
l'ensemble des acteurs que leurs efforts
ne pourront pas être poursuivis cette
année et surtout monsieur le ministre
quel orientation allez vous donner lors
du prochain comité interministériel pour
permettre effectivement la poursuite de
ce transport en 48 tonnes unean
approuvée et demandée par les
professionnels locaux je vous remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à monsieur
Clément Beaune ministre chargé des
transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
manier merci de soulever ce sujet qui
est effectivement extrêmement important
pour votre département de la Marne comme
pour beaucoup de territoires pour
lesquels l'économie sucrière et
betteravière est essentiel j'associerai
si vous me le permettez de le dire ainsi
à ma réponse le ministre l'agriculture
et qui nous travaillons étroitement sur
cette expérimentation elle était une
attente très forte elle a eu lieu nous
en avons depuis quelques semaines vous
le savez les résultats le bilan si vous
me permettez cette expression et
globalement positif je me dois d'être un
tout petit peu plus nuancé que la
panorama que vous avez tracé puisque un
certain nombre d'acteurs professionnels
notamment dans le secteur des transports
sont plus nuancés que les professionnels
de l'agriculture et de la filière sur
l'expérimentation et certaines
collectivités locales nous ont fait
remonter quelques difficultés pour être
tout à fait complet parce que l'impact
sur les chaussées l'entretien des routes
notamment pour les plus petites communes
est important je suis prêt avec le
ministre culture à vous proposer
peut-être deux choses extrêmement
rapidement d’abord pour la campagne qui
va s'ouvrir que nous regardions si nous
pourrions prolonger les choses pour
donner cette respiration attendue à la
filière deuxièmement pour la suite et
nous devons regarder avec la
concertation le rapport plus en détail
consultez notamment l'association les
départements de France consulter
l'Association des maires de France dans
les toutes prochaines semaines
recueillir leur avis début 2024 savoir
si au-delà de ces phases
d'expérimentation nous irions vers une
reconduite voire une généralisation en
tenant compte car nous devons le faire
objectivement et sincèrement des
difficultés qui sont remontées tant je
viens 6 par les petites communes pour
leur équipement et leur voirie que pour
les filières de transporteur donc
prenons ces quelques jours pour prendre
une décision rapide pour la campagne qui
s'ouvre et stabilisons les choses début
2024 pour la campagne qui va s'ouvrir à
la fin de l'année prochaine et que nous
ayons un cadre clair stabilisé et
consensuel je l'espère je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jocelyn de
signe pour le rassemblement nation al
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Santé
monsieur le ministre le cancer et de
loin considéré comme la maladie du
siècle chaque année en France 2500
enfants sont touchés par un cancer
pédiatrique chaque année en France 500
enfants meurent d'un cancer pédiatrique
la raison est simple les traitements
pour adultes ne sont pas adaptés aux
enfants nos médecins ont besoin de la
recherche pour les soigner seulement
voilà la recherche médicale c'est le
parent pauvre bien loin des
préoccupations de l'État qui n'investit
que 2,2% de son PIB sur 49,5 milliards
d'euros la loi de programmation de la
recherche 2021-2030 ainsi que la
stratégie nationale de santé 2023 2033
montre leur limite à l'heure où nos
voisins allemands eux ont doublé leur
budget pour y consacrer 128 milliards
d'euros et où les États-Unis eux ils
consacrent pour leur part
792 milliards
ces pays ont des résultats trouvent des
traitements mais ces derniers ne sont
pas accessibles aux enfants de France ce
n'est pour autant pas une fatalité notre
pays a la possibilité de réduire le
nombre de décès de nos enfants de
manière significative et pour cela il
est de notre devoir de mobiliser
d'encourager d'accompagner nos
chercheurs en leur donnant les moyens
nécessaires pour faire leur travail ces
hommes ont des compétences précieuses
pour notre santé il faut leur donner les
moyens suffisants pour qu'il reste en
France
alors Monsieur le Ministre quel signal
avez-vous à leur adresse et aujourd'hui
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre de
la Santé de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
permettez-moi tout d'abord de saluer
l'initiative septembre en or qui est
relayé dans cette hémicycle notamment
inlassablement par Michel Lausana et
Sandrine Josso et qui vous a réuni et
nous réuni tous autour de cette grande
cause qui est que sont les cancers
pédiatriques les cancers pédiatriques se
sont des souffrances intolérables des
souffrances pour les parents pour les
enfants ce sont aussi des solidarités
inoubliables et je pense ici aux
soignants qui de l'Institut Gustave
Roussy à l'Institut Paoli Calmette en
passant par l'IA chopé à Lyon tous les
jours aident soigne et roches et
cherchent pour trouver des solutions et
aujourd'hui sur les 2500 concert
pédiatriques qu'on diagnostic chaque
année en France 80% trouve une solution
mais monsieur le député vous l'avez dit
20% de ces cancers aujourd'hui sont des
maladies qu'on arrive pas à soigner et
je présiderai dans quelques jours le
comité de pilotage de la stratégie
décennale sur le cancer et je peux vous
l'annoncer ici la priorité des priorités
c'est celle de l'investissement dans la
recherche dans la recherche pour ces
cancers pédiatriques parce
qu'effectivement les protocoles de
recherche sont plus longs sont plus
difficiles dans l'optimisation
thérapeutique c'est aussi un point
important dans l'accompagnement des
familles c'est un point décisif dans
l'identification des déterminants de
santé qui conduisent au cancer et en
effet nous devons une mobilisation
collective une mobilisation collective
qui fait aussi que la France doit rester
très haut dans l'accès aux médicaments
innovants et contrairement à ce que vous
avez pu sous-entendre aujourd'hui on a
accès aux médicaments les plus innovants
pour soigner les cancers pédiatriques en
France les soignants le savent j'en
finis en soulignant aussi l'intérêt des
délais d'accompagner les parents et je
salue pour ça notamment l'initiative et
les lois portées les professionnels
portées par votre collègue Paul
Christophe merci merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre monsieur destiné monsieur le
ministre Maëlys est atteinte d'un cancer
des os elle aurait aimé être ici
aujourd'hui pour entendre votre réponse
mais elle est clouer sur un lit
d'hôpital du haut de ses 13 ans elle se
bat pour trouver des fonds pour la
recherche et sensibiliser la population
à la lutte contre les cancers
pédiatriques monsieur le ministre elle
attend de vous une réponse claire
qu'allez-vous faire concrètement pour la
recherche et surtout quand allez-vous le
faire
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Bastien Lachaud
pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre 19 bombardements et plusieurs
centaines de victimes civiles en Egypte
exécutées par le régime d'altissy voilà
le bilan de l'opération française Siri
très loin des objectifs de lutte contre
le terrorisme qui était invoqué à
l'origine et vous le saviez des notes du
renseignement militaire le prouvent
d'ailleurs le classement secret défense
de ces notes est-il légitime il vise
uniquement à faire obstacle à la
manifestation de la vérité la complicité
de la France dans ses crimes il est donc
contraire à l'instruction générale sur
la protection de la Défense nationale il
aurait fallu cesser immédiatement cette
coopération et dénoncer son détournement
fait par l'Egypte mais qu'avez-vous fait
porter plainte contre le média disclose
et la journaliste Ariane lavrieux qui
ont révélé ce scandale avec quelles
conséquences 40 heures de garde à vue
pour la journaliste et une perquisition
dans le seul but de débusquer ses
sources ce sont les principes fondateurs
de notre République de dans d'autres
démocratie que vous bafouez complicité
des crimes d'un régime dictatorial
usage illégitime du secret des forces
atteinte à la liberté de la presse
madame la Première ministre il est
urgent que c'est cette dérive
autoritaire
madame la Première ministre allez vous
retirer la plainte du ministère des
armées allez-vous garantir le secret des
sources des journalistes allez vous
cesser la persécution d'Ariane lavrieux
allez vous lever le secret défense sur
l'opération sirly allez vous condamner
les crimes du général altissi allez-vous
cesser enfin de vendre des armes qui
servent quotidiennement à réprimer le
peuple égyptien
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Eric Dupond-Moretti ministre de
la Justice et garde des sceaux
merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député ne vous en déplaise
la justice de notre pays est totalement
indépendante
je
vous remercie
le ministre ce n'est pas une réponse je
ne vous ai pas interrogé sur l'action de
la justice je vous ai interrogé sur la
plainte que le gouvernement a déposé je
vous ai interrogé sur le choix que le
gouvernement a fait de classer secret
défense des notes de la Direction du
renseignement militaire qui ne vise qu'à
une chose cacher la culpabilité de la
France mais alors dans des actions
illégales merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre de la Justice
monsieur le député lorsque l'action
publique est en marche
et bien la justice doit faire son
travail et si la justice estime que
cette plainte ne doit pas prospérer elle
le dira et si elle estime le contraire
elle le dira également en toute
indépendance une fois encore une fois
encore une fois encore une fois encore
mais c'est ma réponse ne vous en déplaît
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole
[Musique]
vous êtes libre de vos questions le
gouvernement est libre de ses réponses
la parole est à Monsieur Ludovic Mendes
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre des
Sports et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de France ce vendredi 8
septembre a été marqué par le début de
la Coupe du monde de rugby au Stade de
France par une magnifique et fantastique
victoire de du 15 de France face au
black
est en fan de rugby en 5 jours amateur
je suis avec beaucoup d'attention et
d'émotions la Coupe du monde que nous
accueillons en France d'ailleurs
d'autres coupes du monde ont eu lieu
juste avant celle-ci la Coupe du monde
militaire qui s'est déroulée en Bretagne
au cœur de la circonscription de notre
collègue Nicole lepay nous a permis de
voir l'équipe de France triomphé et
sacré championne du monde fierté que je
sais partager sur l'ensemble des bancs
de la représentation nationale avec
quelques collègues nous avons aussi
participé à notre coupe du monde des
parlementaires où nous sommes invaincus
avec quatre victoires en quatre matchs
et merci madame la Présidente pour les
honneurs du début de séance c'est donc
un sans faute pour notre rugby nous
espérons collectivement que le but du XV
de France continue sur cette belle
dynamique et c'est l'occasion de
souhaiter à nous blesser un prompt
rétablissement
permettez-moi de remercier de féliciter
l'ensemble des bénévoles et des clubs
qui font vivre ces coupes du monde sur
l'ensemble du territoire comme cela se
fait à Metz grâce au SMS Moselle cet
amour du rugby qui nous partage m'oblige
à paraphraser Mathieu blanc formidable
entraîneur du 15 parlementaires et
éminents joueurs du Stade Français que
nous portions le maillot d'une équipe
professionnelle ou amateur que nous
jouions un jeune match de championnat ou
une coupe du monde les émotions et les
frais et les frissons que nous procure
ce sport sont les mêmes en effet lorsque
l'on sur le prêt vêtu de nos couleurs
l'effort collectif le respect de
l'adversaire et l'envie de gagner nous
stimule toutes et tous nous sommes à la
mi-temps de cette Coupe du Monde pouvons
lire nous pouvons lire même dans les
médias que nous explosons les compteurs
mais qu'en est-il vraiment quel est-il
du bilan a mis parcours madame la
ministre conjointement avec le ministre
de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin vous êtes
régulièrement sur le terrain pour vous
assurer de la bonne organisation des
matchs dans les 10 villes hautes de
cette Coupe du Monde nous savons que la
Coupe du monde de rugby est un challenge
d'organisation comme le seront l'année
prochaine des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pouvons-nous avoir
confiance en notre capacité à rayonner
et à faire vivre au monde une expérience
spectateur et storytique et touristique
pardon à la hauteur de nos ambitions je
vous remercie
et mon cher collègue la parole est à
Madame Amélie ou ministre du Sport
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Mendes
je n'ai jamais vu une ambiance pareille
c'était dingue c'était insensé ces mots
sont ceux de Jonathan Sexton
l'emblématique capitaine de l'équipe
d'Irlande à propos du Stade de France
samedi soir oui notre coupe du monde de
rugby est un immense succès populaire
avec déjà un million de spectateurs dans
nos stades ce qui est près de 20% au
dessus des chiffres de la dernière Coupe
du monde plus de 500 000 personnes dans
les fans nos villages rugby dans les dix
collectivités des audiences télé
historiques à l'étranger mais aussi en
France avec un pic par exemple à 17
millions pendant le match d'ouverture et
des ventes de maillots qui dépassent
toutes les prévisions mais surtout un
public heureux un public heureux grâce à
la qualité du spectacle sportif mais
aussi parce que cette Coupe du Monde
vous l'avait dit est particulièrement
bien organisé
passer le temps des rodages on est au
rendez-vous grâce à l'action de Gérald
Darmanin des forces de sécurité
intérieure et du concours apporté par
les stadiers nous sommes au rendez-vous
de la sécurité grâce à l'action de
Clément Beaune à celle des opérateurs de
transport et des collectivités nous
sommes au rendez-vous de la fluidité
dans les transports dans le respect du
dialogue social et grâce à un travail
d'équipe autour du comité d'organisation
France 2023 avec les préfets localement
et les volontaires on est au rendez-vous
d'une expérience spectateur optimisée à
laquelle je veille tout personnellement
site par site et à laquelle je
continuerai de veiller rencontre après
rencontre j'ajoute que cette Coupe du
Monde portant plus des engagements qui
sont forts sur le plan écologique social
de l'inclusion et pour le rugby amateur
et aussi y compris pour le rugby féminin
le roi Charles III lors de sa visite
récente disait vous méritez tous nos
remerciements pour ce tournoi
exceptionnel que vous accueillez avec
tant de panache ces mots au nord notre
pays
renforce notre confiance pour la suite à
10 mois jour pour jour de l'ouverture
des jeux olympiques et paralympiques
pour lesquels oui nous rayonnerons alors
les valeurs du rugby merci
non je suis désolé mais deux minutes
c'est déjà deux cases
la parole est à madame Isabelle Santiago
pour le groupe socialiste merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères nous sommes nombreux
à condamner avec force l'injustifiable
agression militaire dans ces à nouveau
rendu coupable Azerbaïdjan envers la
population arménienne de la République
du hardsa cette attaque indiscriminée
n'a rien à voir avec la guerre c'est la
poursuite du processus d'extermination
des Arméniens engagée par le régime
criminel de Bakou il s'agit d'une
épuration ethnique ce crime d'agression
de nouveau de l'Azerbaïdjan survient
après qu'il était interdit tout
approvisionnement en nourriture et en
énergie du peuple arménien du
haut-karaba depuis le 12 décembre
dernier 120000 Arméniens dont 30000
enfants risque à chaque instant leur vie
alors indignons-nous déjà des vies ont
été perdus voir l'exode du peuple
arménien sur les routes du haut karaba
est un crève-cœur nous pleurons
aujourd'hui depuis ce week-end avec la
diaspora arménienne de voir ces images
la France a un lien historique et
fraternelle avec l'Arménie il est du
devoir de notre nation d'agir madame la
ministre la France a fait un communiqué
claire sur la question mais désormais il
faut des actes cette fois la France doit
demander l'adoption sans délai d'une
résolution du Conseil de l'ONU demandez
une force d'interprétation
internationale saisir la Cour pénale
internationale pour engager des
poursuites contre le dirigeant à l'if de
l'Azerbaïdjan et je les avoir en France
nous attendons également que Paris
apporte un soutien logistique et
opérationnel à l'Arménie dont nous
savons que désormais elle se trouve sur
la route d'une attaque via le sulnique
nous attendons plus nous voulons des
interventions et nous voulons surtout
sauver le peuple arménien
la parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Santiago vous avez raison
l'opération militaire engagée par
l'Azerbaïdjan il y a quelques jours et
injustifiable et d'acceptable la France
la condamnée et elle a condamné à
nouveau lors d'une réunion au Conseil de
sécurité il y a quelques jours demandez
et obtenu par notre pays
alors nous voyons aujourd'hui c'est vrai
les conséquences de cette offensive est
plus que jamais je veux redire que
l'Azerbaïdjan porte la responsabilité du
sort des populations arméniennes duo
Karaba notre opposition est claire nous
y travaillons avec nos partenaires et
alliés aucune paix durable ne pourra
être atteinte dans le Caucase par la
force ou par la menace de la force nous
sommes mobilisés
jusqu'au plus haut niveau et la France
je le redis est engagée avec ses
partenaires européens américains
notamment afin de parvenir à une paix
négociée et juste respectueuse du droit
international et ce sera possible que si
certaines conditions sont respectées je
les dis au Conseil de sécurité aucun
rabat nous demandons le libre accès
humanitaire bien sûr et la garantie pour
les populations arméniennes qui vivent
de pouvoir continuer d'y vivre en paix
en sécurité dans le respect de leur
culture et de leurs droits les
discussions entre Bakou et Séba dunker
doivent se tenir sur les hospices de la
communauté internationale nous le
demandons également pour ce qui concerne
l'Arménie nous demandons le plein
respect de l'intégrité territoriale de
ce pays la délimitation de ces
frontières le retrait des armes massées
par l'Azerbaïdjan dans certains points
du territoire avenir et je rappellerai
madame la députée que c'est une mission
d'observation européenne c'est grâce à
la France elle est située en territoire
arménien voilà le son de notre action
j'ai ajouté tout à l'heure
l'amplification de notre aide
humanitaire elle a plus que doublé
bientôt triplée au bénéfice de l'Arménie
comme des populations du haut-karaba je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Emmanuel
Antoine pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente le 19
septembre dernier laserbaïdjan a attaqué
les Arméniens du au caramar en violation
du cessez-le-feu du 10 novembre 2020
cette agression se fait au mépris du
droit international et vise à imposer la
loi du plus fort elle intervient après 9
mois d'un blocus qui a privé de
nourriture de soins d'éducation et
d'électricité les 120 000 habitants de
ce territoire et je leur ai dit dont
30000 enfants après avoir provoqué une
grave crise humanitaire l'Azerbaïdjan a
précipité le haut carabar dans l'abîme
de la guerre plus de 200 personnes tuées
et 400 blessés dont de nombreuses
victimes civiles sont à déplorer à
l'issue de ces affrontements le peuple
arménien peuple martyre paye une fois de
plus le prix du sang en étant victime
d'injustice géopolitique le sentiment
d'abandon des Arméniens du haut-caraba
est à la hauteur de leur dénuement les
voilà désormais contraints à l'exode
plus de 13000 réfugiés sont arrivés en
Arménie au terme d'un voyage sans retour
laissant tous leurs biens laissant toute
leur vie laissant toute leur histoire
derrière eux c'est une culture multisé
la destruction des traces de la culture
arménienne a déjà commencé avec la
destruction de quatre chars et d'église
la crainte d'un nettoyage et
nico-culturelle est plus forte que
jamais nous devons impérativement
apporter des garanties de protection aux
Arméniens du au carambar l'inaction
coupable de la communauté internationale
a permis le drame qui se joue
aujourd'hui dans le Caucase au-delà des
paroles il faut des actes car
l'Azerbaïdjan pourrait ne pas arrêter là
et poursuivre ses attaques contre
l'Arménie dont elle occupe illégalement
une partie du territoire alors madame la
ministre la France va-t-elle organiser
l'envoi d'une mission internationale
particulièrement nécessaire pour
garantir la sécurité des Arméniens du au
carambar
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Catherine Colonna ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députés
Antoine je vous remercie de votre
question qui m'offre l'occasion de
compléter mes réponses précédentes et en
particulier de dire ce qui est aucun
pays aucun n'être davantage l'Arménie
que notre pays vous le savez très bien
c'est vrai sur le plan diplomatique
toutes les réunions du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies toutes sans
exception se sont tenues à l'initiative
de la France et c'est également je le
disais à l'initiative de la France
qu'une mission d'observation est
déployée en Arménie
c'est aussi sur le plan humanitaire mon
ministère a déployé depuis le début de
l'année plus de 5 millions d'euros en
faveur de l'Arménie et des populations
familiales du haut Karaba et j'ai décidé
au vu des événements des derniers jours
de porter cette aide beaucoup plus haut
avec 7 millions d'euros supplémentaires
nous avons également renforcé notre
relation de défense avec l'Arménie
puisque vous demandez des actes un
attaché de défense sera présent à
l'ambassade de France à Erevan et puis
nous ouvrirons prochainement une antenne
consulaire dans la région de Sonic près
de la frontière donc ce sont des preuves
tangibles je crois madame là députée de
la présence déterminée de la France aux
côtés de l'Arménie
l'abandon de l'Arménie par la Russie et
la complicité même de la Russie avec les
opérations militaires engagées par
l'Azerbaïdjan rendent encore plus
nécessaire une action diplomatique
internationale aux côtés de la France je
souhaite que nous ayons l'Europe plus
encore elle doit prendre acte de cette
réalité agir avec nous pour le respect
de l'intégrité territoriale de l'Arménie
et pour préserver le droit des Arméniens
duo Karaba à vivre s'il le souhaite dans
le respect de leurs droits historique au
Karaba voilà ce que nous faisons
mesdames la député merci d'encourager la
diplomatie française à le faire plus
encore pas seul et avec d'autres elle en
a besoin je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la séance des
questions au Gouvernement est terminée
la séance est suspendue